جايبه في راسي
كده شويه بس انا بعيد شويه
ايوه تمام
ايوه كده معقول شويه اوكي احنا كده على
الهوا
والله
[ضحك]
ما لي دعوه يعني هو النهارده يعني ايه
احنا مش عارف اكرر الاعتذار والله احنا
غيرنا كل حاجه في في حاجه غلط لكن احنا
خرجنا بره الكاميرا تماما وابتدينا نخرج
من الموبايل لغايه ما نشوف حجم المؤامره
لافساد هو بيتظاهر ان هو بيصلح بس الله
اعلم يعني
معلش سامحونا المره دي ونستانف الاجابه
على اسئله حضراتكم
ولو كان حد انا قطع في المرات اللي قطع
فينا عليها الانترنت او او ايا كان السبب
استاذنكم يعود السؤال وانا مع حضراتكم
هنا صاد او صاد يقول السلام عليكم استاذ
السيد في خدم بالهروله نحو التطبيع مع
الرئيس بشار الاسد لملل الموقف الاقوى وما
هي اوراق كل الطرف وكيف ستساعد الجميع
العربيه بحاله الازمه السوريه شوف ما فيش
طرف اقوى في طرفين سلموا بانه ما فيش طرف
قادر على الغاء الاخر يعني وعلى فكره ده
مش في الساحه السوريه بس ما ده كمادر في
الساحه اليابانيه في الساحه الليبيه ان
الاطراف بتقول انه ما حدش مفيش طرف قادر
على الغاء الطرف التاني بالتالي بعد 12
سنه من الصراع انا الاوان ان احنا نجلس
على مائده المفاوضات وما تكونش المعادله
صفريه يعني الغيك تلغيني نقعد ونحاول
نتفاهم وعليه
بعتقد انه بشار الاسد ما كان له ان يستمر
هكذا الى سنوات الوضع مش
قابل للاستمرار الدول العربيه مش قادره
تتحمل فكره تجاهله وعزله لمزيد من الوقت
زي ما قلت لحضرتك كل طرف عنده مصالح انا
كنت مش حابب ان انا اكرر تاني اذا طلبتها
اكرر لان انا مش متاكد
حضرتكم تابعتوا المقاطع التي يعني افتترت
ولا لا ولكن في اثناء الحوار سوف نعود
اليها مره اخرى وطبعا اذكر حضرتك انك ممكن
ترجع للحلقه
الكامله اللي هي عن كواليس التطبيع مع
بشار الاسد اللي هي الحلقه الرئيسيه
الاخيره السؤال الثاني بتقول
كيف ستساعد جميع العربيه بحل الازمه وانت
بتقول ما هي اوراق كل طرفه اوراق كل طرف
انه الاسد في ايده واحد انه بشكل عاجل جدا
ضبط الحدود بحيث انه ما تبقاش في فوضى على
الحدود اهم المخدرات بالنسبه لملف الحدود
لكن المساله مش بس
المخدرات ما انت عندك ممكن تبقى فيه قريبه
منظمه ممكن يكون في ارهاب ممكن زي ما
الاردن قلقانه ان يكون فيه ميليشيات
ايرانيه ممكن تعمل لها قلق على الحدود
عندك الملف زي ما كنا بنتكلم الملف
الايراني هما كانوا بياملوا به الاطاحه به
ان هم يقللوا النفوذ الايراني فشلت
المحاوله تقليل النفوذ الايراني بالمواجهه
العسكريه الان هي مولو بان هم اذا قاموا
علاقات مع بشار الاسد انه تقل حاجته الى
ايران وبالتالي يقل النفوس ايران هذا ما
ياملوه
اهم ملف في جعب بشار الاسد هو اللاجئين
انه يفتح ابوابه او يفتح يعني القنوات
التفاهم لعوده اللاجئين اللي بيمثلوا كثير
وليس كلهم ضغط على الدول اللي بتستضيفهم
اهم اوراق الدول العربيه طبعا كثيره جدا
المساعدات العاجله جدا
الاستثمارات محاوله التوسط لدى اوروبا
والولايات المتحده لرفع العقوبات مجرد ان
هم يبداوا في عمليات مفاوضات معهم ودعم
الشرعياته وتثبيت لمكانته ده باختصار ايه
دور الجامعه الدول العربيه ملهاش يعني دور
كبير جامعه الدول العربيه منتدى تلتقي في
الدول تجميد العضويه لسوريا
كان ممكن تجمد عضيته في جامعه الدول
العربيه لكن كل ده طبعا كلام نظري يعني
لكن تبقى في الدول كثيره اقامت العلاقات
لانه العلاقه طبعا منطقيه ان في علاقه بان
كل الدول تجمد العضويه وتقطع علاقتها اذا
عاد لجمعه الدول العربيه معناها اشاره ان
هذه الدول ترغب في اعاده العلاقات اعاده
العلاقات نقطه بدايه يعني انا موافق نقعد
مع بعض مش معناها ان المشاكل اختفت معناها
انه اصبح انا مستعد ان اتفاوض معك على
النقاط اللي كانت محل خلاف بدل ما انا
اتفاوض معك بالمدافع وبدعم الجامعات
المعارضه عليك ولا خارجه عليك انا اتفاوض
معك في امل للوصول الى حل
هل من الممكن ان
يطبق بشار الاسد الشروط ده طبعا اجابته في
المقطع سوف اعيده مره اخرى
ويطبق القرار 22/4 وخمسين والتنازل عن
الحكم لحكومه انتقاليه وعوده اللاجئين من
بعد جرائمه بحق الشعب السوري وما هو مصير
الفصائل المسلحه المعارضه طبعا دي من
مروان
[موسيقى]
شوف فكره انه هو ايه اللي حصل اللي حصل
انه دول العربيه كانت عاوزه كل اللي انت
تقول عليه ده انه يطيحوا بشار الاسد او
يتنازل عن الحكم وكانت عاوزه انها تمكن
اخرين من الوصول الى الحكم بالقوه
العسكريه
هذه المحاولات فشلت على مدار 12 سنه
واستطاع بشار الاسد بدعم روسيا وايران انه
يحبط هذه الطموحات فما تم احباطه في
الميدان العسكري بتكلفه عاليه جدا من غير
المقبول انه يقبله الان يعني ده مش مش
وارد يعني فردا على سؤالك مستحيل منطقيا
ان يتنازل لكن ممكن انه يتم التسويه في
المستقبل مع التسويه انه يصلوا الى صيغه
الصيغه ديت تقول انه اعمل عمليه سياسيه
والعمليه سياسيه ديت اما انا لا اتقدم
للانتخابات او يتقدم للانتخابات خليفه شخص
يمثلني شخص قريبه مني شخص يضمن مصالحه
ممكن لكن في الوقت الحالي هذا امر غير
مطروح
حضرتك بتسال على ايه تاني كنت بتقول
انت بتقول بقى من بعد جرائمه في حق الشعب
السوري ما هو طبعا ما هو الجرائم ديت اللي
بتقول عليها في حق الشعب السوري هذا هو
موقف ملايين من السوريين اللي هم بيمثلوا
الرافدين لبشار بس ده مش رايي بشار ولا
راي المؤيدين له فالاجابه المختصره لا لا
يمكن ان يتم ذلك ولكن يمكن ان يفتح باب
التفاوض على امل انه تحفظ مصالح بشار
والحكومه السوريه وفي نفس الوقت تبتدي
يبقى فيه بقى تفاهمات على مصير اللاجئين
والمعارض مصير المعارضه المسلحه هيكون
طبعا محل خلاف في ناس هيسمحوا لها بالعوده
لبلدانها في ناس ممكن يتم العفو عنهم في
ناس سوف يلاحقوا في ناس تفتح لهم ابواب
اللجوء لدول اخرى يعني من الملفات الشائكه
جدا ربما يكون احد الملفات اللي هو طبعا
الملف الاكبر هو اللاجئين لكن مصير
المعارضه المسلحه يعني هيكون برضو ملف
شائك
لكن ما اعتقدش مستحيل حله يعني لانه في
تجارب سابقه انه تم التفاوض مع المعارضه
المسلحه والعفو عن بعضها
وعدم العفو عن بعضها الذي لا يتم العفو
عنه بيبقى عنده اختيار انه يلجا لدول اخرى
هل تتوقع ان تتاثر العلاقه بين ايران
وسوريا بعد المصالحه العربيه مع سوريا
سؤال جيد جدا بس ده مرتبط بسيناريوهات
كثيره جدا جدا جدا جدا اولا الموقف الرسمي
لايران انها تمارس هذه المصالحه وهي تبارك
هذه المصالحه لان نظريا بتفترض امرين
الامر الاول ان هذه المصالحه لن تكون على
حساب مصالحها وهي بتفترض ذلك
لسبب واضح انه بشار الاسد لا يمكن ابدا ان
يدير ظهره للدوله التي بذلت الكهود الاكبر
في مساعدته ثم ان بدء المصالحه مع الدول
العربيه لا تعني ابدا انه يثق بها ولا
يتثق به ولكن الضروره ذات ان الاطراف كلها
تجلس على مائده المفاوضات السبب الثاني ان
هي تدرك ان وضع بشار الاسد في هذه الظروف
الاقتصاديه الصعبه لا يمكن ان يستمر وعليه
هي صحيح حقيقه انتصارات على ميدان العسكري
يعني في مواجهه خصومه لكن تدرك انه لابد
ان تحدث انفراج اقتصاديه حتى لا يسقط
النظام وتضيع كل مكاسبها وعليه
فهي بتامل بتتمنى انه هذه المصالحه
تبقى استكمالا للانفراجه بينها وبين دول
الخليج
تحدث تناقضات اللي عاوزاها بعض الدول
العربيه لا تريده ايران ايران تعتقد ان
لديه القدره ان هي تحافظ على مصالحها حتى
وان خسرت بعض امتيازتها المطلقه في مقابل
ان يظل النظام الحليف قائما على قدميه
برضو في تفاصيل كثيره تتوقف شكل المصالحه
مدى قوه الانفتاح بين الدول العربيه مدى
المسارات ما في خلافات كتيره القضايا
النهائيه تبقى محل خلاف كبير يعني لكن دي
الاجابه المبدئيه
اسماعيل
وكان فينا اخونا
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام
اسماعيل بيقول تحياتي وشكرا لجهودكم
برايك الى اين يتجه تتجه ايران في
المستقبل المنظور في ظل التوقف المستمر
للمفاوضات النوويه
التصعيد مع اسرائيل وانفتاح ايران على
محيطها العربي شوف الوضع في ايران ازمه
ازمه كبيره انما
الازمه دي لابد لها من حل
الحل احنا اتكلمنا عنه قبل كده هم كانوا
يتمنوا انه يكون في مفاوضات وايران عاوزه
المفاوضات على ملفها النووي لكنها تؤخر
هذه المفاوضات
امل على اعتبارين ان امريكا غير مستعده
علشان عمليه عسكريه عليها
واسرائيل غير قادره علشان عمليه عسكريه
عسكريه عليها منفرده وتدرك انه قرار شن
عمليه عسكريه على ايران يعني حربا واسعا
لا تريدها لا ايران لا تريدها الى
الولايات المتحده ولا تستطيع ان تتحملها
اسرائيل وبالتالي هي عاوزه تؤخر المفاوضات
فتستفيد امرين الامر الاول تكون تقدمت في
ملفها النووي اكثر واكثر وبالتالي تستطيع
وهذه الهدف الثاني تحصل على امتيازات اكثر
من الولايات المتحده واوروبا
طبعا الهدفين دول في ظل حقيقه اخرى انه هم
مش عاوزين يدوها اللي هي عاوزاه يعني
عاوزها بعد كل من وجهه نظرها يعني هي
استثمرت كثيرا وضحت كثيرا تريده هدفا
يستحق يعني
دي الازمه الازمه بقى دي حسابات ايران هل
دي حسابات امريكا واسرائيل مساله هتكون
خاضعه لتطورات كتيره اداره امريكيه جايه
في الغالب الاداره الامريكيه الجديده اذا
اتت هتكون
يعني عندها حسابات مختلفه اسرائيل عندها
مشاكل داخليه هائله جدا هل تهرب منها اشك
ان هي تهرب منها بضرب ايران تقدر تهرب
منها بعمليه غزه او عمليه محدوده جدا في
جنوب لبنان لكن مش عمليه ضئران هذا يكون
انتحارا وغباء سياسيا احنا لسه على الهواء
انما
كمان ايران مش ساكته هي بتعمق علاقتها
بالصين بتعمق علاقتها بروسيا والجديد هي
تعميق علاقتها او مش تعميق علاقتها يعني
تذويب الجليد بينها وبين دول عربيه هذا
يصعب قرار اتخاذ موقف عسكري ضد الضحك قد
يكون الحل في المستقبل انه الولايات
المتحده ببساطه واسرائيل تسلم امرها لله
وتتفاوض مع ايران باعتبارها اصبحت قوه
نوويه زيها زي كوريا الشماليه وزي باكستان
يعني
ده برضو سيناريو مش هيكون مريح للدول
العربيه
نعم
الاسئله كثير جدا بيقول لي طيب ما احنا
عقبنا الناس وقعدناهم كتير مش اقل حاجه
بقى نحاول ان احنا نفارس فارس بيقول لي
ازيك ازيك يا فارس ربنا يخليك
هل دخل هل دخل العالم ده محمد
عطقان هل دخل العالم فعلا مرحله القطبين
متمثلين في الولايات المتحده والصين ولو
كان المجال قطب ثالث فمن هو الاقرب ليقوم
بهذا الدور
يا استاذ محمد انه فكره المرحله القطب
الواحد التي بدات بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي في ديسمبر 92
واستمرت لنحو 20 عاما يعني
مثلا لغايه 2016 15 حاجه زي كده
دي مرحله بدات تتراجع وبدات الولايات
المتحده تكون غير قادره ان
تحكم نظاما يقوم على القبه الواحده هي مش
قادره من ناحيه ارهقت ومن ناحيه تانيه في
دول اصبحت اقوى مما يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان يعني تدومينايت او تسيطر اللي هي الصين
فضلا عن روسيا فضلا ان في الدول كبيره
بتمشي بهدوء بس اصبحت كبيره صعبه من
الولايات المتحده يعني
تسيطر عليها تماما زي الهند مثلا حجم
الغضب على السياسات الامريكيه بيتعارض
اقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا وسياسيا دول زي
البرازيل دول زي جنوب افريقيا دول كثيره
دول في المنطقه العربيه حتى الدول اللي
كانت حليفه جدا للولايات المتحده زي
السعوديه زي الامارات
دول زي الجزائر دول حتى يعني كانت بتتج
نب انتقاد الولايات المتحده علنا لكن
غضبها على الولايات المتحده واضح زي
زي الدول الاوروبيه زي فرنسا مثلا زي مصر
في المنطقه كتير يعني دول افريقيه
وبالتالي
الخلاصه انه الوضع محل انتقاد اصبح دلوقتي
في نظام جديد بيتشكل
مش بالضروره يكون في الصين وولايات
المتحده ممكن يكون في صين وولايات متحده
وفي كتل اخرى بتسعى للاستقلال زي مثلا
الرئيس الفرنسي عاوز الاتحاد الاوروبي
يكون الهند ممكن تلعب دور دول البريكس
ككتله ممكن تبقى قطب واحد لكن ده مساله
بتتطور يصعب انك تجزم بشكل العالم النظام
الجديد لكن تقدر تجزم بشيء واحد بس ان
النظام اللي كان قائم على
قطب واحد وامريكا في المركز هذا النظام
ولا باي باي ولن يعود كما كان مش معناه ان
امريكا هتبقى دوله ضعيفه معناها تفضل دوله
قويه لكنها لن تكون الدوله
المسيطره على كل مقاليد الامور
احمد جمال ما هو تحليلك لاسباب تاخر
برنامج الطروحات وتاريخ سعر الصرف استنتج
ان انت بتتكلم على مصر الاسم والسؤال انا
قتلت كالاتي بالمناسبه وانا قبل اذاعه هذه
الحلقه في حلقه بعنوان
ما مدى ما مدى حجم
الاقتصاديه في مصر هي حلقه طويله حوالي 45
دقيقه مع صديقي العزيز الاقتصادي هاني
جنينه وكنا بنطرح فيها هذا السؤال وفيها
رد كامل على سؤالك لكن بما انك سالت فاحب
اقول لحضرتك انه
تاخر تحرير سعر الصرف في تقديري له سببين
السبب الاولاني انه التضخم والاسعار
مرتفعه جدا جدا في مصر طيب مرتفعه في مصر
لاسباب كل الناس عارفاها منها ان سعر
الدولار بقى في السوق الموالي وصل لحوالي
اربعين جنيه اذا اصبح سعر الدولار في
السوق السوداء 40 جنيه والتجار بيسعره
اسعار على 40 واكثر من اربعين اذا رحت انت
تشتري مثلا هذا الهاتف فهو مقدر سعره انه
مشتريه بكذا لكن في وبالتالي الغلا موجود
لكن اذا قامت الحكومه الان في وسط هذا
الغلاء بتحرير سعر الجنيه واصبح هو في
البنك اصلا من 31 زي مثلا الى 40 في البنك
او حتى اقل من كده ده معناه ان في سلع
اخرى بالغه الاهميه سوف يقفز ثمنها ايضا
لم تتحرك هذه
السلع حتى الان لان من يشتري هذه السلع
الحيويه يشتريها بسعر الجنيه الرسمي في
البنوك سعر الوقود سعر الادويه المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه جدا زي القمح والذره
الى اخره
ده واحد فده بيخلي الحكومه تفكر مرتين في
عواقب هذا القرار اثنين انه
الديون الداخليه مرتفعه جدا عشان هي ترفع
سعر الجنيه ترفع سعر الدولار
قصدي تحرر سعر الجنيه ويبقى الجنيه بقى
رسميا ب 40 جنيه ده معناها انه هتبقى في
عبء كبير على الحكومه وعلى تكلفه الاقتراض
وعلى التضخم وهتضطر ترفع اسعار الفائده
علشان تنجم التضخم ما هو هيحصل تضخم اسعار
الادويه هتغلى اسعار الذره هتغلى المواد
الاساسيه يعني الطاقه هتغلى النتيجه انه
هو لازم هيجد انه عنده انفلات في التضخم
هيضطر يرفع اسعار الفائده اسعار الفائده
هتكبل النشاط الاقتصادي اللي هو مكبل لانه
هيخلي تكلفه القروض عاليه جدا وهيخلي
تكلفه ديون الحكومه اللي هي بتقترض بسعر
الفايده اللي في السوق مرتفعه جدا ودي
مشكله كبيره هي بتنتظر تامل انه تجد
توقيت افضل لتحرير سعر الصرف لاعتبارات
تتعلق بقى بمفاوضاتهم مع اطراف مختلفه
تاخر برنامج الطروحات ان الدوله تبيع اصول
مملوكه لها كما طلب الصندوق وكما يعتقد
كثير من الاقتصاديين انه حل لان في ناس
بيعتقدوا ان الدوله بالغت جدا في النشاط
الاقتصادي بحيث اصبح نصيب
الاستثمار في مصر 70% للدوله في مؤسسات
المختلفه الدوله ديت عن القطاع الاعمال
يعني مؤسسات مثلا ولايه القوات المسلحه
يعني مؤسسه الداخليه مؤسسه يعني ايا كان
هذه المواسات كلها دوله اصبحت 70% والقطاع
الخاص 30 في الميه تاخرت ليه لانه
في عده مشاكل اهمها انه اللي عاوز يشتري
ده عاوز يشتري على سعر صرفه واضح اشتري
على الجنيه الدولار اللي هو ب 31 في البنك
ده مش مقنع لانه غير عادل انا عاوز اشتري
على سعر اعلى طيب عشان اشتري على سعر اعلى
الدوله مقتنعه ان السعر ده مشوه وبالتالي
مختلفين على الاسعار
ده احد الاسباب ده احد الاسباب
سيدي هناك عملاء مشهورين مثل كوهين وصلوا
لاعلى المناصب
بما يمنع زعماء العرب من ان يكونوا جواسيس
مثل ملك الاردن
قال والله يا علي محمد هناك عملاء مشهورين
مثل كوهين وصلوا لاعلى المناصب كوهين اللي
هو وصل في سوريا في ستنا على ما اذكر يعني
اذا كنت بتتكلم على
المثل اللي هو وصله بقى مسؤول في وزاره
الدفاع على ما اذكر انت بتقول ما يمنع
زعماء العرب من ان يكونوا جواسيس مثل ملك
الاردن مثلا وسيسي طب هو يبقى جاسوس لمين
يعني هو رئيس الدوله هيبقى يعني
يعني
عموما هي وجهه نظر تحترم بس انا لا اشاركك
الراي انا بقيت ملك الاردن القصه بلاش ملك
الاردن عشان انت كده عمليات تشخيص ولا انت
بتتكلم عن رئيس المصري ولا اي حد اللي انت
واضح ان انت عاوز تنتقدهم يعني واحد وبقى
ملك دوله واحد بقى رئيس دوله ما الذي
يدفعه للعماله كلمه جاسوس يعني انا باخد
مرتب اخر الشهر الكلام اللي اثير عن مثلا
اثاره هيكل عن الملك حسين ما كانش ان انا
ابقى جاسوس ان الملك الاردن يحصل على راتب
ايام كارتر قبل وقفه من السي اي اي كلام
هيكل وكلام صادر استند اليها هيكل
محمد حسنين هيكل الصحف المصري الشهير
والحقيقه ما جابهاش من عنده هي موجوده في
عده مصادر الامريكيه ما كانش لان الملك
حسين يبقى جاسوس ولكن كان ان ده رجلنا
الحليف معانا واحنا في مقابل خدماته
الجليله
بنجري له راتبا هل هذا امر يعني يسعد
الملك حسين يعرفه اذا كان هذا الامر حقيقي
فهو امر طبعا بيبقى يعني محرج ولكن مش
لانه جاسوس للاردن ولكن لان انا على علاقه
بهذه الدوله وهذه دوله تعتقد انه انا
احتاج الى راتب اجريه مش ان انا اديك راتب
وتتجسس لي على وزاره الخارجيه وتتجسس لي
على وزاره
اذا كنت فهمت سؤال حضرتك وعموما دي مسائل
بيبقى اثباتها صعب
يعني احمد جمال مؤخرا دعا الرئيس
رئيس مين بقى انت احمد جمال ده انت اللي
سالت سؤال بشويه بتتكلم على مصر دع الرئيس
الى الحوار الوطني ولجنه عفو رئاسيه
وصياغه استراتيجيه لحقوق الانسان كيف تنظر
الى هذه المبادرات وما هي النتائج
المتوقعه لا اعلم عنها شيئا يا احمد لا
اعلم الكثير مش متابع بعمق انه لكن نامل
انها تنجح
وربما كويس ان يبقى في حوار وطني كويس ان
تكون المساله محل جديا انا مش متابع
وبالتالي انا مش عارف مش متابع ده تقصير
مني مش عدم اهتمام يعني
ولكن كان طبعا ممكن الحوار الوطني يكون
جدواء اكبر بكثير لو كانت تم عقده مبكرا
لاسباب واضحه لكن نتمنى ان هي تنجح على كل
حال ان تاتي متاخرا خيرا من الا تاتي ابدا
فسامحنا ليس لدي اجابه قاطعه في هذا الامر
عمر لماذا تستخدم بعض دول اوروبا عملات
غير اليورو يعني ايه مثلا سويسرا ما كانتش
عاوزه تبقى جزء من العمله اليورو مثلا
السويد ولا النمسا اللي عندها الكورونا
مين مش
اختلط علي الامر يعني الدول اللي هي مش
عاوزه تستخدم اليورو رفضت ان تكون جزءا من
كتله اليورو كانت شايفه ان انا اكون جزء
من كتله بتستخدم عمله موحده ده هيقيد
قدرتي على التحكم في سياسه النقديه اطبع
قد ايه ارفع الفايده قد ايه سوف اصادر
واحد من اهم صلاحياتي السياديه في التحكم
في سياسه النقديه
لحكومه مركزيه بتدير مجموعه دول كل دوله
لها ظروف مختلفه فتكانت تتصور ناس شايفين
انه اوكي لا نبقى جزء من يورو واحد زعمتها
طبعا المانيا لانها كانت اكبر المستفيدين
وفرنسا رات ان هي سوف تكون ثاني اكبر
المستفيدين بقيه الدول التانيه كانت تامل
ان هي تكون في ظل هاتين الدولتين
الكبيرهتين في دول تانيه حاسه ان مصالحها
نتعاون مع الاتحاد الاوروبي اوكي لكن لا
اكون جزءا او حتى يعني
اتعامل معه على كل الصعود لكن لا اكون
جزءا من الكتله
كتله اليورو يعني ما يناسبهاش
طبعا كانت بريطانيا مش الازهر الاشهر يعني
ظلت قبل ان تخرج من الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت
جزء من الاتحاد الاوروبي
جزء من الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكنها رفضت ان
تكون جزءا مش بالضروره ان انت تبقى عندك
نفس عمله اليورو هذا اتفاق مختلف
مؤخرا دار لماذا لماذا لا تستثمر الحكومات
تخافون فعلا من مجتمع متعلم وواعاعن
ويفضلون بقاء الجهل اظن ان بعض الحكومات
تفعل ذلك فعلا تفضل ذلك يعني التعليم مش
من اولوياتها يعني
عمرو موسى يجب اعداد الناس لمستقبل صعب
لماذا يقف عمرو موسى على مصير البدل بلد
ومتى تنتهي الازمه الحاليه عمرو موسى يخشى
على مستقبل البلد لانه هناك اقرار بان مصر
فيها ازمه ازمه كبيره
البارز فيها جدا هي الاقتصاد بس الاقتصاد
ده مش حاجه ثانويه يعني مثلا مش مش عندها
هذا اذا اختل الاقتصاد كل شيء بيختل لانه
الناس ممكن تقبل مثلا ان دولتها تتبع
سياسه خارجيه هي مش راض عنها لكن اذا
المساله بقت فيها مشاكل اقتصاديه
ووصلت المشاكل لمعايش الناس واعقها
بتحم حاله من عدم الرضا وبالتالي تبدا
تبقى في مشاكل اضطرابات في عمرو موسى تعبر
عما يجيشه في صدور
عشرات الملايين من المصريين من خلال كلمته
قدام الحوار الوطني
متى تنتهي الازمه الحاليه تنتهي الازمه
الحاليه بانه الدوله الحكومه تحديدا
تتراجع وتعيد النظر في السياسات اللي
اتبعتها فساهمت في تفاقم الازمه الازمه
جزء منها ناتج عن تغير في الظروف الدوليه
واحد لكن ايضا مزيج من السياسات اللي
تبعتها الدوله
ومثلا دايما المشكله الاكبر هي في توسع
الدوله في الانفاق على مشروعات يمكن ان
تكون لها عوائد وفوائد على المدى البعيد
التكلفتها الان كبيره جدا اكثر مما
تحملتها الخزانه العامه للدوله وقدرات
الدوله والعائد منها على المدى الحالي
والقريب يعني مش موجود فهذا احد الاخطاء
الكبيره واخطاء اخرى في ادا ره الملف
الاقتصادي اذا تراجعت عن هذا الملف
وقدرت تدير المرحله الانتقاليه للخروج من
الازمه ديت هيبقى ممكن فيه امل ان شاء
الله والامل موجود باذن الله
معلش يا احمد انا هرجع لك حالا بس علشان
ندي فرصه لحد تاني احمد جمال ده اسماعيل
انا هرجع لك يا احمد بس معلش ادي فرصه
للاخرين
اسماعيل هل تتجه الامور في سوريا الى
اقامه معادله رضعه ضد الهجمات الاسرائيليه
على الاراضي السوريه لاسيما بعد الزياره
الاخيره للرئيس الايراني الى سوريا اذا
كانت الاجابه بنعم فكيف سوف يتم ذلك لا
صعب طبعا لانه يعني ايه قله الرضع وسيله
الرضع انه تكون ما هو اسرائيل ما فيش حاجه
هتقنعها الا انه تتاكد ان ايران لن تكون
موجوده في سوريا والهدف الاساسي احد
الاهداف الاساسيه من كل التضحيات
الايرانيه ان هي تكون موجوده داخل سوريا
عشان سوريا مهمه وعلشان سوريا هي معبرها
للبنان وعلشان سوريا هي تدعيم لنفوذها في
العراق وعلشان وجودها في الثلاث دول هو
رضع لاسرائيل ان انا بعاصرها قريب منها
قادر على خلق وتدعيم اكثر من حزب الله
جديد ده الامل دي الاستراتيجي ثم ان وجودي
في سوريا وجودي في لبنان
وجودي في العراق هي وسيله للدفاع والهجوم
المتقدم بعيدا عن اراضي دي فلسفه وادي
استراتيجيه ايران
اسرائيل مدركه لدهوا بتحاول ان هي تضرب
الوجود الايراني قبل ان يكتمل قبل ان
يكتمل يعني قبل ان يصبح حزب الله لانه لو
يصبح حزب الله جديد ما هي مش قادره تضرب
حزب الله في لبنان لان التكلفه هتكون
عاليه
عاوزه تنتظر حتى تكتمل الظروف وتكتمل
تصنيع الاسلحه
والافراد ويعملوا بقى الخنادق السريه
بتاعتهم طبعا وبناء عليه هتفضل مستمره يا
رب ممكن تعمل ايه
مثلا بطاريات دفاع جوي هي بتضرب جزء منها
بيتضرب قبل ان ياتي او بيضرب وهو بيعمل
فكل طرف منهم طبعا بيحاول لكن يعني صعب ان
انت
تحقق الردع في الوقت الحالي بين سوريا
واسرائيل على غرار الرضع اللي موجود مع
لبنان هذا ما تامله ايران وهذا ما تسعى
لاحباطه اسرائيل من ينجح
مساله تحتاجه ان ننتظر ونرى
بي ام ان انت رجل محترم ربنا يخلي حضرتك
اعتقد انترنت السبب وانا اعتقد انه ماندو
هو السبب
حاضر يا احمد
هل ده اخونا ام اتش ام دي عليه هل تتوقع
تتاثر العلاقه بين ايران انا مش عارف اجبت
هنا انا اعتقد اجبت في طيب تمام
هل المشروع الناصري سبب خراب
سبب خراب
سوريا والعراق عمر
لا يعني طبعا صعب ان انت تتوقع اجابه
منصفه انت بتتكلم على حركه القوميه
العربيه لقد عبد الناصر من يعني اوائل
الخمسينات الى يعني وفاته في سنه 70
سبتمبر 70
هي فتره طويله تابع سياسات كتيره بعضها
كان له ايجابيات وبعضه كان له سلبيات انا
عارف ان بعض المسؤولين العراقيين شافوا
انه تدخلات عبد الناصر ودعمه لزعماء
معينين يعني او قوى معينه ادت الى تدمير
العراق مساله فيها نظر بس بصفه عامه
التجارب الكبيره اللي هي استمرت سنين
طويله وكان مؤثره جدا زي تجربه القوميه
العربيه صعب ان انت توصل لاجابه
ميسوره وقاطعه ومحل اتفاق كل تجربه من
التجارب العميقه زي تجربه القوميه العربيه
ديت لها وعليها سواء في البلد اللي هو
مصدرها اللي هي مصر مصر عبد الناصر او في
الدول اللي تاثرت بها ما في دول ما زالت
بتقدس عبد الناصر انت انا كان استاذي اللي
هو طبعا العالم الكبير الدكتور محمد
دويدار احد اهم علماء الاقتصاد يعني العرب
مدرس فيه كثير من الدول العربيه منها
افريقيا كان بيحكي لي ازاي ان هو بيفاجئ
ان في قرى من مجاهل افريقيا
متماثله عبد الناصر موجوده لانه ساعدهم في
التحرر فانا يعني اقدر اقول لك انه مساله
دي بعيد يعني عاوزه دراسه ان انت تصل الى
[موسيقى]
انما لو عاوز اجابه مختصره لا يمكن يكون
هي السبب الاساسي والرئيسي لخراب العراق
وسوريا بعراق سوريا بلدين كبار وتضافرت
عوامل كثيره اوضح وابرز من دور عبد الناصر
الاجابه السريعه يعني
دعواتكم لاهل غزه ده دعواتنا جدا جدا لاهل
غزه ربنا يعني يخفف عنهم ويعني وينصرهم
ما المقصود بتجديد الخطاب الديني ولماذا
تعثرت دعوه الرئيس السيسي الى التجديد انا
عفوا انا لست احدى اختصاص يعني
قال لا فقد افتى انا اعرف حاجات قليله
افضل التركيز عليها لكن فيما يتعلق
بالشريعه والدين والشكل الصحيح للاسلام
لست افضل من يتحدث اخونا
برشاد محمد شكرا لعودتك استاذ جبيل انا
شاكر انك لصبرك
ونعتذر للانقطاع احنا على فكره عملنا
تغيير غيرنا الكاميرا لانه واضح ان في
تغيير اليوتيوب مش عاوز فكره ان احنا نطلع
مباشر بكاميرا عاوزه تغيير في البرامج
فعدنا الى ما بدانا به
عدنا الى الموبايل
انت عامل الموبايل بقى كذا ولا في حاجات
هتطلع وكلها
افصل اتاكد لاحسن يجي لك مكالمه
[موسيقى]
بندق خدمه رهائن
ماشي يا احمد انت بتقول احمد جمال مره
اخرى مال المسؤول عن الازمه الحاليه هل هي
نتيجه اللواء كوفي 19 وحرب روسيا ام انها
نتيجه للنموذج الاقتصادي المعتمد من قبل
الحكومه بالاعتماد على الديون وتثبيت سعر
الصرف ومنافسه القطاع الخاص والله سؤال
جميل جدا يا احمد انا يقينا الاجابه قصيره
بس استاذنك النهارده النهارده يعني انا
بدات النهارده
المباشر 9 قبل ان يعني بغض النظر انه
اتقطع كذا مره لكن انا اذعت حلقه على نعرف
اقتصاد عن مدى عمق الازمه المصريه وبنتكلم
فيها عن الاسباب والتحليل لكن اذا اردت
اجابه مختصره في تقديري المتواضع بعبر فيه
عن نفسي انا وليس عن غيري فانا اعتقد انه
في اسباب اثرت على دول كثيره منها مصر
كانت مؤثره ووضعت هذه الدول في وضع صعب
جدا جدا جدا ادي لك مثال قبل ما اجاوبك
اجابه كامله تخيل انه قبل ازمه كورونا ثم
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كانت هذه الدول
الدول اللي هي الناشئه الدول الناميه بجرت
نفسها بعد هذه الحرب وبعد ازمه كوفي 19
عندها مشكلتين في منتهى الصعوبه واحد انه
هي كانت
بتستدين وبالتالي الامور كانت ماشيه يعني
تسدد دينا بدينا وبتعمل مشروعات تنمويه
شويه وتعيش الناس شويه وكل دول العالم
بتستدين مش هم بس يعني
وجدوا بعد ازمتي كورونا وكوفيد 19 وبعد
ازمه كورونا والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
انه عندهم صعوبه شديده في الاقتراض لانه
الولايات المتحده رفعت اسعار الفائده
الاموال الساخنه اللي كانت بتستثمر في هذه
الدول من اجل طمعا في ان هي تكسب منها من
فارق سعر الفائده يعني امريكا هتدي له 1%
مصر هتدي له خمسه سته في الميه يبقى يروح
لمصر فجاه امريكا رفعت اسعار الفائده
اصبحت الاموال دي كلها خرجت خوفا اولا
طبعا في الربح الامن في امريكا وخوفا من
احتمال عجز مصر والدول اللي هي الناشئه من
ان هي تعجز عن سداد ما تقتلده من هؤلاء
المستثمرين في الاموال الساخنه
ده واحد اتنين انه بعيدا حتى عن الاموال
الساخنه اصبحت القرود مرتفعه جدا جدا جدا
اخر سعر يمكن ان تقترض به مصر اذا ذهبت
للاسواق الدوليه قد يتجاوز العشرين في
المئه على الدولار انا استلف مليون ادفعه
مليون و200 الف مقارنه بخمسه وسته في
الميه وسبعه في الميه قبل الازمه فرق مهول
جدا جدا اضف الى ذلك بقى غير صعوبه القروض
كل السلع الرئيسه من وقود وغذاء وادويه
ارتفع ثمنها لانه
اثبتين خلقت ازمه امدادات اللي هي
وكمان في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه جعلت
وصول كثير من هذه السلعه الاساسيه قليل
وصعب فاصبح عندك
السلعه الاساسيه غلط
تضاعف سعرها مش غلى 5% 10%
و400% في بعض الساعه
واحد اتنين انه
قدرتك على الوصول للقروض اللي ممكن تشتري
بهاديات اما انه اغلق ما حدش عاوز يسلفك
انا ما بتكلمش على مصر بس على دول اخرى او
اصبح مكلف جدا ضع كل هذه المشاكل التي
جاءتك من العالم الخارجي واضف اليها طبعا
اخطاء واضحه جدا من الحكومه المصريه اللي
توسعت في مشروعات انا عارف ان الكلام ده
ممكن يستفز كثير من المسؤولين ولكن هذا
رايي وهم فاتحين الحوار الوطني وبيسمعوا
من الناس اعتقد انه كان هناك خطا كبير
مشروعات القوميه على اساس افتراض ان
الامور سوف تتزل قائمه وان احنا اذا
انفقنا على هذه المشروعات سوف تكون كاذبه
للاستثمار ونحقق
وتحقق مصر طفره غير مسبوقه لكن لم يؤخذ في
الحسبان ان دوام الحال من المحال ومش
بالضروره انه مصادر التمويل تظل قائمه
ورخيصه وسهله فكان هذا خطا
يعني من الحكومه احنا عندنا شغالين عادي
لا انا بتكلم احنا على الهواء ولا حصل
حاجه يعني انا لو ضغطت على اوكي
فالخطا مشترك يا صديقنا يعني
عندنا ماذا يحدث في فلسطين واسرائيل محمد
امين اللي بيحدث فيه فلسطين واسرائيل هي
نفس السيكل العنف انه اسرائيل
هي الوضع دايما بيكون كالاتي اسرائيل بتضع
ده التشخيص اللي هو ينطبق على الازمه دي
وعلى الازمه السابقه وعلى الازمه السابقه
وهكذا ايه اللي بيحصل اسرائيل وطن
عده ملايين من الفلسطينيين سواء في غزه او
في الضفه او اضف اليهم العشرين في الميه
من عرب اسرائيل بس طبعا دول ظروفهم يعني
اقل حده من الفلسطينيين موجودين في غزه
وفي الضفه تحت ضغط عنيف جدا الضغط العنيف
جدا ده بيولد من وقت للتاني عمليه رد فعل
بقتل مستوطن بتنفيذ عمليه هنا هناك
اسرائيل تصف هذه الخطوه بانها ارهاب
واستفزاز ويجب قطع كل من يفكر عشان ترضعه
وتقطع يده بتقوم بعمليه عنيفه جدا جدا جدا
اذا قتلتولي اسرائيلي واحد سوف اقتل عشرات
واحيانا مئات فتبدا سايكل للعنف اللي هو
متمرد انت عاوز بتقول ايه اللي بيحصل
اسرائيل بتضرب غزه بتضرب الضفه لانه
ببساطه هي تستطيع ضربهم بدون تكلفه تذكر
واحيانا بيكون ضربهم حتى بدون اي سبب فقط
هم بيقولوا ديت بيسموها سياسه العشب الجزر
والعشب يعني انا اترك الجهه مثلا منظمه
الجهاد او المقاومه بايا كان اشكالها
لفتره يبتدي يطوعوا الكوادر فاقوموا
باغتيالهم وقتلهم وانتظر قليلا يبتدوا
يطلعوا الكوادر وهكذا
واعملها حتى اذا لم يستفزوني واعملها مش
بالضروره ان انا اتخلص منهم بس لان هم
ممكن يمثلوا علي خطرا في المستقبل لان انا
عندي مشاكل داخليه في اسرائيل وعاوز اشتت
الراي العام اشغله الى اخره
محمد ماهر هل من
الدقيق القول بان الازمه السودانيه
استفحلت بسبب ضعف الدول المصري فيها
بالمقارنه بالدور الروسي الاماراتي
الاثيوبي تبقى يعني فيها ظلم شويه على مصر
مصر في الاخر يعني بتلعب دور ودور مهم مش
تفضلا على السودانيين ولكن ده عشان
مصالحها مصالحها كبيره جدا جدا جدا في
السودان وده اتكلمنا عنه في اكثر من حلقه
انما هل من المنطقه يقول انه لانه مصر مش
قادره تلعب الدور ده كويس فاستفحلت الامور
المصالح اللي مصالح الدول كثيره موجوده في
السودان وعجزت ما اثيوبيا دوله عجزت تشاد
عجزت كل الدول السابعه اللي محيطه
بالسودان عجزت هتقول لي الدول ديت اقل
شانا يعني هقول لك طيب ما في دول جوار غير
مباشر دول الخليج قادره عجزت الولايات
المتحده عجزت روسيا عجزت
انما هو اللي تقدر تقوله انه
انا انا تصوري يعني انه لما بتكون في
الدول زي السودان او زي ليبيا او زي اليمن
ده تقدير يعني انه الازمه عنده بتبقى ذات
شقين الشق الاول انه اهل هذا البلد عاجزين
على ان يتوافقوا وبصراحه كده بدون مقاربه
يعني
الامور في هذه الدول سوف تستقيم اذا كانت
هناك قوه واحده قادره على فرد رؤيتها يعني
في اطار هذا الفوضى صعب ان هم يتوافقوا
بطريقه ناعمه هيحتاجوا يعني ربما مئات
السنين صعب جدا خصوصا اذا لم تكن هناك
اراده دوليه لا لام هؤلاء
الفرقاء عندك حل من اتنين للسودان او لاي
ازمه يعني انه يكون في طرف اقوى بكتير من
الطرف التاني هذا غير متحقق وعليه هيفضل
دايما في حاله نزاع لان الخلافات كبيره
جدا ده اللي ظهر جزء من الجبل الجليد
المتوقع لا قدر الله اذا طال امد الا زمه
انه ده ينسحب الى قوى اخرى ما زالت تراقب
المشهد جوه السودان وعلى اطراف السودان
السبب التاني ان القوه الخارجيه بطبيعه
الحال عندها مصالح متباينه في السودان وفي
غير السودان لما بيكون في قوه قويه ودوله
مركزيه واضحه الدول دي بتحترم نفسها وما
بتقدرش ان هي
[موسيقى]
تتدخل بشكل يعني يؤجج المساله مع عدم وجود
قوه مركزيه وفي فوضات الدول دي بتتدخل
بنفسها املا في الحفايه الحفاظ على
مصالحها لما بتتدخل بتزيد الامر سواء بس
ردا على سؤالك لا يعني
كده يعني
تحميل لمصر اكثر مما تحتمل
معلش انا هرجع لك تاني يا احمد انا شاكر
الاهتمامك كتر خيرك بس حتى وكذلك لاحمد
ماهر هرجع لكم استاذنكم بس اعطي فرصه
لاخرين
[موسيقى]
حد بيقول لي اتشك انا معرقه شك ايه بقى
احمد
بيقول اتشك فمش عارف يعني اتشك على ايه هل
ممكن ان تتحدث عن مبادره ده بولتر عن
مبادره الخطوه خطوه الاردنيه
وماذا تختلف عن سابقتها وما فرص نجاحيها
انا ما اعرفش ان في سوابق لها لان خطوه
الخطوه خطوه الاردنيه طرحت سنه 21
كمبادره مكتابله فما اعرفش ان في مبادرات
مختلفه جذريه لكن عموما سواء كان في او لا
مبادره الخطوه خطوه خلاصتها كده انه
الدول العربيه عاوزه الكثير من بشار الاسد
وهو ينتظر منها الكثير في مقابل فبتقول ان
التطبيع من الدول العربيه
ودور الدول العربيه فان هي تتوسط وتحاول
اقناع الغرب الولايات المتحده
برفع
او العقوبات ياتي خطوه خطوه يعني مثلا
نبدا اول خطوه يا جماعه الخير في سوريا من
فضلكم اوقفوا اضبطوا الحدود يتوقف ضبط يتم
ضبط الحدود ويتوقف تهريب مثلا للكبتاجون
دي بدايه طيبه في المقابل
ندعمكم زي مثلا بمساعدات
[موسيقى]
لتخفف من حده الازمه يرد مثلا بشار الاسد
بان المساعدات ديت لا يشترط ان تكون فقط
لمن يقعون تحت سيطرته ولكن للجميع في
مقابل انه يسمح بكده تبدا الدول العربيه
اطلب من الغرب انه يرفع بعض العقوبات اللي
هي ذات طابع عاجل وانساني يرد بشار الاسد
بانه يبدا بالسماح له فئات لا محل لا
خلافه عليها للاجئين خطوه في خطوه
مش تتفرتات يعني واحده بواحده
مرتبطه اكتر بالصدام يعني ولكن خطوه هنا
خطوه هناك تبدا في حل الازمه وصولا بقى
الى الملفات الكبيره اللي هي بطبيعتها
شائكه لكن سوف تصبح اقل صعوبه اذا بدانا
بالخطوات الاقل حساسيه
ياسين بيقول هل يمكن ان تعمل فيديو عن
الصناعه في العالم العربي مشكورا لا ما
اقدرش اعمل فيديو عن الصناعه لان هذا ليس
تخصصي ولكن لدي بعض الاقتصاديين اللي هم
متخصصين في مجال الصناعه ممكن نستضيفهم
ويتكلموا عن الصناعه
ويبقى دي اضافه جيده جدا وفي ناس قضت
سنوات في دراسه ملف التصنيع في العالم
العربي يعني
نسعى لهذا باذن الله هل ممكن ان تصمت
حكومه اليمن اليمين الاسرائيلي بالرغم من
عدم رضا الجيش الاسرائيلي الولايات
المتحده عنها
محمد شوف احنا اسرائيل برضه عندها مشاكل
وهي مشاكلها تشبه الولايات المتحده وتشبه
الى حد ما تركيا في ايه فانه انت عندك
يعني مجتمع عنده احزاب كثيره قوي يعني
عشان
وجه التشابه انا هقوله حالا انا اقصد ايه
بالتشابه في التركيه والولايات المتحده بس
الاول اتكلم على الحلقه الاسرائيليه هم مش
قادرين يخرجوا بره عباءه نتنياهو ليه
نتنياهو لان نتنياهو بيمثل حزب الليكود
اللي هو اكبر حزب يميني كان الحارث في
اسرائيل منذ تاسيس هذه الدوله وهذا الكيان
في اواخر الاربعينات انه القوى الكبرى فيه
هو حزب العمل او القوى اليساريه ثم بدا
اول مره يمكن يفوز حزب الكود اللي هو
اليمين كانت 78 79 اللي هو تفاوض مع مصر
على اتفاقيه السلام ثم بداوا يتبادلوا
المواقع اليسار اللي هو حزب العمل واليمين
اللي هو الليكود ثم في العشرين سنه اللي
فاتت تراجع اليسار تماما وكلمه اليسار في
اسرائيل تقدر تختصرها اللي تهمنا اللي هو
راغب الى حد ما في التفاوض مع العرب
الفلسطينيين اللي كود تقدر تختصره في ان
هو
المتشدد جدا في رفع رايه الامن وشدد مع
العرب والفلسطينيين
فهو بيمثل الكتله الاكبر التيار الاكبر
ليه بقى هو التيار الاكبر اليمين قصه
طويله لكن حصل تغيير سكاني في اسرائيل
حصلت عمليه
توالد تكاثر بين الناس المتدينين
والمحافظين اللي بيخلفوا كتير دول اصبحوا
والمتدينين باشكالهم اصبحوا هم الغالبيه
اللي في المجتمع الاسرائيلي حصل انه
اليسار فشل من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليين في
ان هو يحقق لهم ما اراده اصبح في قناعه
لدى الاسرائيليين لدى الاسرائيليين انه لا
جدوى من التفاوض وهو فعلا ما فيش جدوى من
التفاوض لان المفاوضات عشان تكون مجديه
لازم تحقق اهداف الاسرائيليين عشان تحقق
اهداف الاسرائيليين معناه ان مش هيكون في
لا دوله ولا ولا اي حلول ممكن يقبل بها
زعيم فلسطيني النتيجه انه قالوا ما فيش حل
غير ان احنا نواجه الفلسطينيين دول قوه
هذا هو
نتنياهو يمثل هذه الخطوه اصبحنا قدام
امام صراع مش يمين يساري ولكن يمين يمينه
اليمين بقى في اطراف تانيه هي من اليمين
ولكنها مش راضيه عن سياسات نتنياهو لاسباب
ملهاش علاقه لا بالعرب ولا بدول الجوار له
علاقه خلافات داخليه
بس الاطراف ديت صغيره الى حد ما ومنقسمه
على نفسها تكون ائتلاف يهزمها نتنياهو كل
مره كونت ائتلاف واحد هزم نتنياهو في
اواخر 20 21 قعدوا سنه وبعدين جمعوا ناس
من كل حد وصوب تمكنوا فقط من هزيمه ولكن
يحكموا لان هم عرب مسلمون على يسار على
يمين على من كل الالوان يعني فما نجحوش
فاضطروا يرجعوا تاني اللي بيمثل كتله
اكثر تجانسا والى حد كبير قادره ان هي
تحقق اكبر عدد هياتلف مع ناس قريبين منه
يمين يمين جدا يمين متشدد كده يعني
[موسيقى]
انت بتقول هل يمكن ان تصمت لا ممكن ما
تصمتش ممكن تنهار الحكومه بس في الحاله
ديت هيروح الانتخابات سادسه
هيكون بقى مصيرها ايه هل هيقدروا يهزموه
في الانتخابات اشك لكنه لننتظر ونرى
ربنا يحلها من عنده
اخونا
تقول سيد قبيل هل انت علماني ولاحظ كرهك
للجامعات الاسلاميه
يعني انا كلمه علمانيه انا بقول من سنوات
طويله ان العالمانيه هي الحل فانا اعرف
العلمانيه بتعريف واحد لان كلمه العلمانيه
دي بقالهم بيستخدموها 100 سنه وكل واحد
بيستخدمها باسلوب انا بقول علمانيه بمعنى
علمانيه الدوله يعني ان الدوله دي تقف على
مسافه واحده من كل الاديان وتسمح للجميع
بممارسه شعائره يعني حريته الدينيه يهودي
مسيحي بودي كل واحد تحترم حقوقه
وتبقى تقف على مسافه واحده من الجميع
وبعتقد ان العلمانيه بهذا المعنى بهذا
المعنى اللي طبعا هي يعني تقترن بامور
اخرى عشان تكون عندك علمانيه بهذا الشكل
لازم يكون عندك حريه راي لازم يكون عندك
سياده قانون لازم يكون عندك تداول السلطه
بالمناسبه
عكس العلمانيه الحقيقي بيبقى عاده مرتبط
بالنظم الدينيه او الدول اللي بتوظف الدين
بس ده موضوعات كثيره هتنقلنا الى موضوعات
مختلفه انما مش بكره الجامعات الاسلاميه
انا بقول ان الجامعات الاسلاميه ما عندهاش
نموذج تقدر تصدره لاداره دوله حقيقيه لانه
الجماعات الاسلاميه بتقول ان الحكم الا
لله في جوهرها لما تقول له ما تقصد يقول
لك ان انا لازم احكم واطبق الشريعه
الشريعه يعني قوانين يعني تفسيري انا
للدين
في الغالب هيقول لكل اصحاب الاديان الاخرى
انتم مواطنين من الدرجه التانيه ده هيادي
الى اضطرابات في مجتمعات حديثه فيها تنوع
من الاديان والقوميات وافكار مختلفه لكن
اكتر من كده في خطوره عدم العلمانيه ان
المسلمين
ومعظم المسلمين من المليار ونصف مليار او
اكثر يعني بيقتربوا الاتنين مليار بيعيشوا
في دول هم ليسوا فيها اغلبيه زي مثلا
الصين زي الهند زي دول تاني وبالتالي اذا
طبقت نفس الفكره ان الحكم الا للاغلبيه
البوذيين الهندوس
المسيحيين هيكونوا هم بيمارسوا هذه
الاضطهاده على مسلمين في دوالهم
تغطيه رائعه والله السوري احمد اشرف الله
يخليك ويحفظك ماذا يعني عوده مشروطه في
بيان الجامعه العربيه انا ما قراتش كلمه
مشروطه بس انا فاهمها انه احنا لسه كنا
بنتكلم انه تعود سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه معناها هنبدا المفاوضات اولا هو
يعني الدوله العربيه جامعه الدول العربيه
في نوفمبر 2012 قالت هنجمد مقعدها ده
بالاغلبيه كانت في دول معترضه
واقترحت ان الدول تقطع العلاقات لان ده
قرار السياسي جامعه الدول العربيه لا
تستطيع ان تفرضه دلوقتي العوده لجامعه
الدول العربيه معناها انه الدول قبلت ان
هي تيجي جامعه الدول العربيه ويعني ضمنا
بعيدا عن الجامعه ان دي هتكون منصه
ليه لان هم يتفاوضوا مع مع السوريين يعني
فانت بتقول معاوده مشروطه مشروطه بنظام
الخطوه خطوه لسه كنت بتكلم عليها ابداوا
المفاوضات مع السوريين
وكل طرف له تصورات انت تقبل لجين قد ايه
انت هتضبط لي الحدود قد ايه انت هتعمل ايه
مع الوضع في مع الكرد هتعمل ايه مع
الايرانيين
فاذا دوله حاسه ان المفاوضات اصبحت
لصالحها تطبع العلاقات على المدى القريب
مع سوريا اذا وجدت انه هذا لن يصب فيه
صالحها سوف تقطع العلاقات مع الرئيس بشار
الاسد احنا ماشيين تمام والصوت تمام
احمد سوري
دمشق ليفنج
والاردوغان وين
اذا
شوف الاجابه هل اخونا احمد بيقول انا ما
اندمشق وعايش في السودان وما عندوش كيبورد
عربي تمام احمد بسيط يعني
فرص اردوغان في الانتخابات فيفتي فيفتي
خمسين خمسين مين اللي بيقول استطلاعات
الرا
وانا بس اللي قلقني ان انا بشوف صورتي
معمول هنا اعمل بلاي انا عندي تعال بص كده
ما انا دايس لايف بس ده كده اوكي ادوس على
ده
ما انا لو ما هو شغال وهو كده مقفول
يعني ادوس عليه طيب اوكي كده مضبوط تمام
انا اسف يا احمد
احنا اتقطع علينا البث فانا قلقان من كل
حاجه يعني
[موسيقى]
استطلاعات الراي في ابريل وفي اوائل في
ابريل يعني مش في اوائل معي اكتر من
استطلاع رايي بيقول انه تقريبا فرص
الاتنين تقريبا
متساويه وكل واحد عنده في جعبته اوراق
تميزه عن الاخر اكثر ما يميز الرئيس
اردوغان خبطته الطويله في لعبه الانتخابات
وانه باعتباره رئيس الدوله فهو قادر ان
ياخذ مثلا اجراءات زي خفض الدعم زي خفض
خفض اسعار الطاقه خفض اسعار الكهرباء
الاعلان عن مشاريع كبيره اكتشاف بترول كل
الحاجات دي كانت موجوده وبيستخدمها في
الوقت المناسب مش معقوله النهارده بس يعني
اكتشفوا انه مثلا في قدره على تصنيع سياره
تصنيع مركبه كذا تصنيع اكتشاف بترول
الحاجات دي هو هو وحكومته عارفين انه
يستخدموها في الوقت المناسب
عنده هو اصلا ظهور هو الراجل له قاعده
كبيره بس الفرق القاعده الكبيره ديت كانت
مثلا 51 يبقى قدر على فوز بالانتخابات
انما لو القاعده الكبيره ديت بقت 38 ممكن
تكون اكبر من كل حزب المنفرد انما هيكون
38 وهيبحث عن شريك ممكن المعارضه عندها
بقى مزايا وعيوب عندها فكره ان هي
بتستثمر في اولا من ملل كثير من الاتراك
ان انت بقى لك 20 سنه كفايه عليك ده فاتيك
وارهاق طبيعي من
مواطنين في اي دوله من نظام اذا بغى سنوات
طويله اثنين انه في متاعب اقتصاديه بدايه
من 2017 و 2018 بيزيد تضخم كبير بطاله مش
قليله
سعر العمله مرهق جدا
اثنين او ثلاثه انت عندك بقى الزلزال في
فئات كتيره من اتراك ترى ان الحكومه اخفقت
في ملف زلزال مش بس في
المساعدات ولا سرعه انقاذ الناس ده راي
بعض الاتراك وليس كل الاتراك ولكن كمان من
تسبب في الزلزال الزلزال من عند ربنا طبعا
انما المباني التي لم تراعى فيها المعايير
وحقق منهار كثيرون ارباحا وهؤلاء الكثيرين
محسوبين على النظام او تحت سمعه وبصره
طبعا ده يفط في عضد او يدعم المعارضه في
مقابل اردوغان
الانتخابات دي هيكون مؤثره جدا جدا جدا مش
بس على تركيا ولكن على كثير من دول العالم
اذا ذهب اردوغان سوف تتغير الكثير من
السياسات اللي هتاثر بشكل مباشر على سوريا
على الدول العربيه على اوروبا على روسيا
ودي قصه تحتاج يعني تستحق ان نخصص لها
حلقه اتمنى اكون اجابتك انت كان لك سؤال
تاني هل اليمين المتشدد او المتطرف في
السويد مدعوم من روسيا لسنوات طويله دعمت
اليمين في معظم دول اوروبا
[موسيقى]
دعمته وشجعته مستفيده منه
ما انت ما تنساش ان اليمين هي اهم حاجه
بالنسبه لها اذا دعمت اليمين احد اهم
النتائج لان قصه طويله يعني انه اليمين
متافف من الاتحاد الاوروبي ويفضل انه فكره
القوميه وان انا اكون السويد لوحدها
وبريطانيا لوحدها وهكذا وده يفيد طبعا
روسيا ان يكون كل دوله اوروبيه بعيدا عن
هذه الكتله الكبيره اللي بتنسق سياستها مع
بعضها الى اصبحت دول متفرغه كما كانت يسهل
على روسيا ان هي
تتعامل معهم فرادى وليسوا جماعه
معك
داوود الحير ما رايك باعلان انتهاء ازمه
كورونا هل كانت ازمه حقيقيه ام مفتعله
والله لا اعلم يده انا طبعا كنت اتمنى
شكرا لحسن ظني كبير بس انا يعني ما عنديش
يعني معلومات اقدر اقول لك ان اثق اقول لك
انها كانت مؤامره قبلها يعني لكن انا بصفه
عامه بصفه عامه اجت صعوبه في قبول فكره
انه
تتامر مجموعه كبيره من الشركات او الدول
وتنضج مؤامره بهذا الحجم اجتمعوا فين
وثقوا مصالحهم ازاي اخفوا هذا السر ازاي
عاده بكون في صعوبه لكن اللي ممكن اقبله
في ازمه طلعت سواء كانت ازمه مخلقه بطريق
الخطا او مثلا من احد المعامل او ان حد
عملها وكان متخيل حجمها صغير او ان هي
فيروس حقيقي ممكن اتفهم ان ده حصل لكن في
الدول استفادت منها هذه قصه تانيه بقى لكن
ان هم حد اجتمعوا وعملها خاصه ان كل دول
العالم تاثرت بها يعني الكل تاثر بها
سعيد اشكرك يا سعيد الامارات
فصلنا ولا ايه
الامارات ستعلن انفصال جنوب اليمن تاريخ
22 مايو استعدوا للخبر طيب في انتظار
معلومتك يا اخونا حسن هنشوف كيف سوف تعلن
عن انفصال جنوب اليمن يوم 22 مايو محمد
ماهر هل موقف قطر من التطبيع مع الاسد
فعلا بسبب رغبتها في سياسه خارجيه مستقله
ام بسبب تبعيات سياسات امريكا الغير
متحمسه للتطبيع مع الاسد بمعنى لو كانت
امريكا متحمسه هل كانت ستكون قطر غير
متحمسه انا مش عاوز استخدم كلمه تبعيه
والكلمات اللي هي ممكن تبقى افضل اقول ان
هي رغبتها في التحالف ما هي بتختلف مع
امريكا
بصراحه ما اختلفتش مع امريكا في حاجه يعني
ولكن انا اقيدك انا قنعتي انه ايران ان
قطر عندها مجموعه من الثوابت في سياساتها
الخارجيه من الثابتين ان تكونوا مستقله عن
جاراتها وخصوصا الجار بالنسبه لهم في دول
الخليجيه السعوديه وان تكون على عدم لا
تكون هناك تناقضات جوهريه مع الولايات
المتحده يعني في تناقضات الثانويه ممكن
امريكا تكون مش عاوزه حاجه معينه بس حاجه
مش مهمه فقدر تعملها لكن تناقض جوهري لا
فممكن الاتنين الاتنين بمعنى ان هي ترغب
في استقلال سياساتها الخارجيه وحتى لو
كانت امريكا معارضه لانه ممكن امريكا تعرض
ملف وهو مش مهم بالنسبه لها يعني مثلا
مثلا في ملف الاسد ما هي لم تمانع ان في
دول اخرى
[موسيقى]
تطبع مع الاسد ما هي الامارات حليف
والسعوديه حليف ومصر حريف الدول والاردن
حليف كل الدول ديت تبدا التطبيع معناها
انه امريكا مساله مش بالنسبه لي حياه او
موت والا لا
اعربت عن الاصدقاء ان دي مساله خط احمر
كان هيبقى صعب على الدول دي انها تتطبع مع
الاسد وكانت ممكن قطر تعمل اي يوم قطر
اعتقد ان الاجابه ان هي عاوزه تبقى رغبه
مستقله وعندها تصوراتها عن باقي الدول
الخليج
وفي نفس الوقت اعتبار بقى ثاني انما هي
منسجمه مع امريكا في هذا الملف مش عارف
ولا اجابتك
محمد لو قال الاسد الايرانيين ان يرحلوا
عن سوريا هل سيرحلون وهل لديه القدره على
تنفيذ ذلك اذا قال الاسد
للايرانيين ان يرحلوا
تبقى المساله يعني كوميديه يعني الامور ما
بتمشيش كده لكن ممكن يقول ايه انه هم
الايرانيين
اذا قال لهم ارحلوا هتبقى في مفاوضات لانه
لو وصلنا الى مرحله كوميديه جدا انه بعد
الناس ما قعدوا سنين طويله هم موجودين من
تسعه وسبعين وموجودين بقوه كبيره جدا من
دلع الازمه 2011
وضحوا بارقام مهوله من جنودهم ومن حلفائهم
ومن اموالهم وتعرضوا فمش ممكن جدا انه
يقولوا له خلاص كده اتفضل اطلع لكن اذا
حدث انه اذا حدث يعني انا باخد السنه
بتاعك انه هو لا يرغب فيهم وانه علاقته مع
العرب اصبحت مشبعه وكده ممكن اطلب منهم
انه يقلصوا نفوذهم شويه شويه يخلصوا
وجودهم يطلب منهم يعترض على بعض الامور
يقبلوا ببعضها لا يقبلوا ببعضها اذا وصلت
الامور الى مفترق طرق واصبح الخلاف عنيف
مع الايرانيين صعب جدا الايرانيين يبقوا
محتلين لانه بشار الاسد هيطلع ويتكلم علنا
بيقول ان انا لا ارغب فيهم
ويحشد الدول الاخرى المتحده ويحشد الدول
العربيه تلاقي نفسها في مازق ان هي مش
مرغوب فيها وهتبقى مساله صعبه عليهم ده
السيناريو انا اعتقد ان هو خيالي الامور
هتمشي في مسار مختلف شويه انه هيبقى في
مشروع ميناء عاوز يعمله الاسد بدل ما كان
الايرانيين هياخدوه كده كده هم ياخدوه لا
ممكن الاماراتيين ممكن كذا وفي عطاء موجود
يعني الايرانيين هيعملوا ايه يعني هيمارس
نفوز على الاسد ما في دول تانيه عندها
نفوذ
انه في زي مثلا انه هو الجيش عاوز خلاص
استعد واخذ قواته ما عدش فيه مبرر قوي انه
البليشيات او الحلفاء الايرانيين يكونوا
موجودين في كل قريه يعني الامور هتبقى
اذا صارت الامور هتلاقي انه
موازين القوه بتفرض نفسها على كل الاحوال
ممكن ما يسمحش مثلا بدخول قوه جديده اذا
وصلت الضرب تحت الحزام يستطيع ان يبلغ
خصوم ايران عن اماكن وجودهم فالامور يعني
صعبه ان هي تمشي
بالفكره ان انا هقعد ضد رغبه الحكومه ضد
رغبه البلد صعب يعني
انت طبعا هتقول لي طب ما تركيا موجوده ما
هي تركيا موجوده لانه الدوله السوريه ما
كانتش موجوده او هي موجوده الان هو ضعيفه
فهي موجوده بالقوه العسكريه نعم لكن ضد
رغبه الحكومه مش ضد رغبه الجماعات
الموجوده ضد رغبه الجامعات التركيه ليها
دعم من داخل سوريا انما في حاله بان
الامور استقرت لسوريا واصبحت انه لها
حلفاء وان الدوله بترجع رويدا رويدا هيبقى
الوضع مختلف يعني
صعب ان في قوه تبقى موجوده بالقوه
العسكريه والغصب يعني
لماذا اعلام الاسد قابل
قرار الجامعه
قابل الجميع العربيه بحذر شديد وتجاهل
ببعض الاحيان ذكر القرار في نشرته معرفش
انت بتتكلم على مين ولكن ممكن افهم ممكن
افهم التالي
هو القبول في جامعه اولا هو الخطاب اللي
كان موجود من جانب الحكومه السوريه ان
احنا لا نريد العوده لجامعه الدول العربيه
استغنيتم عنا ونحن لا نريدكم وكان بيقول
لن نعود لجامعه العربيه اذا اذا اقروا
بخطائهم واعتذروا لنا لسنا في حاجه
للجامعه الخطاب ده بيخلي من الصعب انه يجي
يقول احنا احتفلنا الحمد لله عدنا الى
الجامعه لانه كان امبارح بيقول لا نحتاج
هذه الجامعه في شيء ده
انه العوده للجامعه
برضو قرار صعب
مش عارف اشبهها بايه يعني احيانا
انك تكون حاجه جميله جدا زي مثلا انه يطلب
منك انك تقعد عندك خلاف مع شراكه تجاريه
مع حد وعندك خلافات والخلافات تعنيفه جدا
وبعدين يقول لك والله خلاص احنا مستعدين
تعالى بدل ما نفضل في حاله خصام تعال نقعد
مع بعض انت خايف تروح لان انت يتطلب منك
امور كثيره جدا عشان تتصالحه فبرده العوده
لجامعه الدول العربيه
هي بالعربي كده هي نقطه بدايه لفتح ملفات
مفاوضات على قضايا صعبه فمش بعضها هيكون
مؤلم لبشار الاسد ولكثير من السوريين اللي
بيسيطروا على مفاصل القرار ده تفسيري لكن
انا لم ارى لم اتابع لا اعرف اللي انت
بتقول عليه انه في ناس قلقانين اقدر افهمه
بس
وللاسد تيك اوفر ذي ادلب
انت عاوزني اجاوب اسئلتك باختصار وانت
بتطرح اسئله صعبه هل الاسد هياخد ادلب ده
شرط الاسد انه ادلب شمال سوريا لا تبقى
منطقه واحده في سوريا دوله داخل الدوله
فهذا شرط يسعى لتحقيقه قصه طويله ومشوار
طويل خصوصا بقى ده يرتبط بتغير بنتائج
الانتخابات في تركيا اذا جاء اردوغان ممكن
يكون التفاوض صعب جدا لانه كان محتاج
التفاوض للاسد بالضروره عشان ينجح في
الانتخابات ويغالي على المعارضه لكن اذا
جاءت المعارضه وجاء كلجدار اوغلو ربما
يكون التحقيق هذا الامر اسهل ليس سهلا جدا
ولكن اسهل السؤال الثاني
هل سوف تطبع اوروبا مع الاسد اوروبا اعلنت
موقفها لا لكن اذا استقرت الامور للاسد
هتبدا روايه ان رويدا ترفع العقوبات
منكر العلاقات تبقى علاقات مقبوله وليست
حاده يعني يعني مش لازم يستقبلوه يستقبلوا
حد بدلا منه ممكن يعملوا تمثيل دبلوماسي
محدود ثم بعد التلات اربع سنين تعود
الامور الى مجاريها لانه مش هيقدر
يتجاهلوك
لو انت حضرتك يسمح يا ريت يا استاذ سيد
اللقاء يكون اسبوعي عشان نستفيد من علم
وثقافه حضرتك اللي صعب نلاقيها على
اليوتيوب انا طبعا بشكر حضرتك يا اسلام
على كلامك الطيب كثر خيرك كنت بنضو وانا
وصادقنا عمرو يعني برضو زميلنا هنا كنا
بنتكلم النهارده ان انا كنت وعدتكم ان انا
هطرح استطلاع رايي نخليها كل اسبوعين كما
نفعل مره كل اسبوع بس انا فضلت ارجاء
الاستطلاع لما بعد هذا المباشر عشان ما
الغبطش الناس النهارده في مباشر فعشان ما
يحصلش انه احنا لسه بنتكلم النهارده خلاص
بكره باذن الله سوف اضع هذا الاستفتاء
وسوف اترك هذا الاستفتاء لعده ايام اذا
جاءت الاغلبيه بنعم ان شاء الله نجرب فكره
مره كل اربعاء كل اسبوع يبقى زي حديث
الاربعاء كده
ونتمنى انه يكون مفيد اذا نجح اكثر ممكن
نفكر فيه افكار اخرى
والورد اللي بيطلع لي ده واللي يكتب لي
100 مئه حد عامل كده يعني حاجه كويسه يعني
متشكرين يا جماعه والله معلش سامحوني انا
انا رجل كبير مسن لا افهم هذه التكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
وقت حضرتك ايه يمنع الحكومه المصريه ده
اسلام من
من طائر النظام ولا تغيير النظام ما اعرفش
من ايه النظام المصرفي او الضريبي
والقبائل للشركات
واللي جذب الاستثمارات
ان كان هذا هو ما يصلح الاقتصاد كما اتفق
جميع الاقتصاديين
من اصلاح النظام المصرفي حاجه زي كده يعني
والضريبي والقضائي بحيث انها تكون جاذبه
للاستثمار عشان دي مش قرارات اداريه يا
اسلام يعني انا اقدر اخد قرار اداري مثلا
مثلا بنقل مقر وزاره العدل من التحرير الى
العاصمه الاداريه اقدر اخذ قرار به ان انا
احصل فورا الان سواء
بصلاحيات السلطه التنفيذيه او بموافقه
البلمان اقدر اخذ قرارات بانه تغيير
النظام التعليم في المدارس اقدر اقوم
ببناء مدينه او مدينتين لكن علشان تيجي
بقى ده بيسموها
يعني
الاصلاح الحقيقي اللي هو الكبير الشامل مش
معناه الباقي وهمي يعني الاصلاح العميق ان
انا اجيب الحاجات البنيويه العميقه انت
عشان تيجي تغير النظام القضائي ده معناها
ايه النظام القضائي ده افراد تقدر تشيل
وتحط بس ده معناه ان انت تغير التشريحات
احنا في مصر عندنا قطع تشريعيه بيسموا
القانون قطعه تشريعيه لو اشتغلت عن القصه
ديت من كم سنه محترمين كده وجدت انه في
مئات الالاف من القطع التشريعيه بتحكم كل
منظومه في البلد اذكر جيدا جدا الدكتور
سمير رضوان الله يدي له الصحه والعافيه
وهو شخصيه اقتصاديه مرموقه في مصر ومتخصص
اكتر في قوانين العمل انه يفاجئني لانه
كان شغال على هذا الملف وسالني السؤال
التالي قال لي كم قطعه تشريعيه تحكم وزاره
الزراعه في مصر
قلت له والله انا عمري حتى ما زرعت يعني
ورده في البيت احنا ممكن نحب الزرع اجيبه
عندي بس لا اعلم قال لي خمن قلت له اكيد
بقى كتير يعني عشرات مئات قال لي 500 الف
قطعه تشريعيه وال500 الف قطعه تشريعيه دي
بعضها يعود الايام محمد علي وبعضها سنه من
عده
شهور يعني
ماء الخلاصه ايه ان بيجي الموظف
يجي انت بتروح له بتقول له مثلا انا عاوز
تخصيص حته القطعه القطعه الزراعيه دي تبقى
مباني او مباني تبقى زراعه ايا كان يعني
فالموظف يفتح على الحاله بتاعتك هو بقى
عنده اطنان من القوانين قانون بيحرم
وقانون بيمنع لو افترضنا في حسن النيه هو
هياخد القانون اللي يعرفه لو افترضنا فيه
سوق النيه هو هياخد القانون اللي عليه
هواء على هواء اما بيحبك او هيستفيد منك
ما ينطبق على وزاره الزراعه ينطبق على
قرارات اخرى كثيره طب ليه ده ما يتغيرش ده
عاوزه عاوزه اراده قويه جدا عاوز رؤيه
عاوزه صبر فيها تضارب مصالح في ناس متفقين
من ان الحاجات ديت موجوده
بيستفيدوا منها اوعي تتصوروا انه رئيس
الدوله يعني السيسي ولا بشار الاسد ولا
ملك هو طبعا ده اكبر سلطه تنفيذيه بس هو
مش هو الدوله يعني هو بيكون
نافذ وقوي لكن هو في الاخر جهد جهد بني
ادم لازم لازم لازم يكون في جهد جماعي هو
رايه ودفعه للامور مهم لكن هتلاقي ان في
ناس كتيره اذا ما كانش لها مصلحه تعطله
تعقد للامور انا اسف ان انا هخرج عن القصه
دي بقصه صغيره ولكن هي في صميم الشخصيه
المصريه شفتها بام عيني كان الدكتور مصطفى
السعيد وهو كان وزيرا للاقتصاد مصر وكان
اقتصادي من اوائل الاقتصاديين يعني توفاه
الله من حوالي ثلاث اربع سنين يقول
المصريين
يهابون السلطه يخاف من السلطه وطبعا ده
الاسباب تتعلق بالجغرافيا يعني منطقه
منبسطه كده الفرعون بيتحكم فيها في مياه
النيل ولكن ايهاب السلطه طبعا انا فقها
ولكن يفرح لسقوطها لانه مش قادر يعمل معها
حاجه كلمه ماشي كلام كده عائم او انشائي
لكن انا شفت الكلام ده بمعنى ايه بقى
المصري لانه السلطه ما عندوش قدره انه
يقومها في كثير من الاحوال السلطه متمثله
في الدوله اللي هي دوله مركزيه على عكس
دول اخرى تقدر تتحكم في مياه النيل تقدر
تتحكم في الاقليم طول مصر طول عمرها مصر
عندها دوله قويه ودي لها مزايا وعيوب يعمل
ايه المصري قليل الحيله اللي ما عندوش قوه
غير انه بيعاقب السلطه بالسخريه والنقطه
والكلام ده
انه يغرق السلطه يغرقها في كم من المشاكل
حتى تسقط حتى ترهق انا شفت الكلام ده من
مصري عادي في اطار عملي اذكر ان انا كنت
في مكان صحفي وكان في اداري دايما مضايق
زمايلنا وكان زمايلنا دول بيشتغلوا في
التنفيذ اللي هو بياخد الكلام ويطلعه في
شكل مجله او جرنان بيسموهم زملا في
التنفيذ والاخراج فزميلنا دول كانوا عشان
يعاقبوا هذا الاداري يقولوا له يطلعوا له
كل مشكله هو ما بيفهمش في الفنيات بس هو
مستبد فكل مشكله تجيلهم وهم عارفين حلها
يقول طب نحلها ليه يا استاذ فلان احنا مش
عارفين نحل دي حللنا فاستاذ فلان ده يلاقي
نفسه قدام تفصيله تفصيله تفصيله كل ما
يطلب منهم حاجه يقولوا له والله فعلا
نتمنى احنا عاوزين ننفذ حضرتك بس احنا مش
عارفين حل لنا المشكله دي حلها ازاي يعني
نجحوا في ان هم يخلوا حياه الرجل الجحيم
لكن في اطار حربهم مع هذه السلطه الظالمه
انهار المكان بعد فتره انا اسف ان انا
يعني
قد حكيت لكم قصه قتله تبدو للبعض ان هي
عود لسؤالك المهم انه هذه الاصلاحات صعبه
جدا عاوزه اراده عاوزه وقت عاوزه
مواجهه لجماعات المصالح اللي موجوده في كل
مؤسسنا
انا ليست سهله
وجماعات المصالح ديت مش مش حاجات صغيره
يعني
الامارات ستعلن ماشي انت قلت الكلام ده يا
اخونا حسن العماني لماذا العرب يكرهون
ايران رغم انها
هي في موقف الدفاع النفسيه ده حسين احمد
هل مجرد الطائفيه او من اجل عيون
الامريكان لا يا احمد
حكايه انه ايران انا طبعا انا دائما بعبر
عن وجهه نظر ايران وموقفها عبرت عن ده
كتير الى درجه ان البعض بيقول لي انت يعني
متعاطف مع ايران لا انا انا مش متعاطف مع
ايران ان انا معاهم على طول الخط انا
متعاطف مع
الصوره اللي بيصورها الامريكان يعني واللي
بتصورها لها اسرائيل واللي متصورينها بعد
الدول العربيه انه
[موسيقى]
سواء ككتله واحده او لكن لا انا بقوله انه
هو بطبيعه الحال هي طبيعه كده انت عايش مع
جارك انت مش هتقدر تلغي جارك خاصه اذا كان
جارك قويا فعليك بدل ما تعادي انك انت
تقوي نفسك وتحاول تتفاوض معه يعني مش
معقوله اللي انا كنت بقوله انه
لابد من ايجاد صيغه للتعامل معهم
ارضاهم في بعض الملفات التفاوض معهم على
ملفات اخرى رفض ملفات بكاملها الضغط عليهم
بملفات لكن يكون في تواصل بحيث ما تكونش
العلاقه سفريه عداء كامل ومواجهه على كل
الصعب تستنزف ايران وتستنزف العرب وعليه
الخطوه الاخيره دي ربما تكون
يعني خطوه موفقه نتمنى ان تكمل والناس
اللي كانوا بيقولوا لنا انت عايش في الوهم
لو كنت عايش في الوهم وجايز ممكن تكون
اخطاء خاطئه بس اللي انا كنت بقوله وعندي
هنا يعني حلقات موجوده منها مثلا حلقه
قديمه متى تهبط طائره الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى في طهران واللي كنت منطقه عليها
اصبحت الان هي مطروح حلقه انه اصبح انه
بيقولوا لي لا ده مستحيل وانه لا يمكن وان
هذا هو راس الافعى تم العرب دلوقتي
والسعوديه دي اخر المطبعين ما هو الدول
العربيه عاشت معها وعاشت دلوقتي وعاش ت
قبل كده
مختلف يعني النظام الاقتصادي عشان يكون
نظام اقتصادي بيكون بيتعامل مع قضايا اكثر
عمقا انا دلوقتي عندي مجتمع هيعمل المجتمع
اللي هيعمل ده محتاج تنظم له مجموعه من
الامور اول حاجه هتنظمها ادوات الانتاج
تملكها الدوله ولا ينتجها الافراد ولا
تبقى خليط محتاجين سؤال طيب هيجي في انتاج
الانتاج ده هيتوزع ازاي والفائض منه يروح
لمين طيب وهكذا ففي الحاجات دي جاوبتها
النظم الاقتصاديه الكبيره اللي هم
النظامين النظام الاشتراكي والنظام
الراسمالي اسهب فيها ووضع قواعد كبيره
عشان يتكلم عليها ما فيش التفاصيل دي في
النظام اللي انت بتقول عليه انه موجود ما
فيش لكن الاسلام جاء في اقر النظام السوق
لان النظام السوق ده موجود منذ بدء
البشريه لما جاء على دول زي مثلا مصر وكتب
ابن الحكم مليئه وللانصاف انا لم اكن اعلم
ذلك لكن علمت انا من استاذ الكبير الدكتور
محمد دويدار اللي اتمنى انه افتتاح الفرصه
وتقراوه هذا عالم جليل الله يدي له الصحه
والعافيه يعني
انه كتب ابن الحكم اللي درسها استاذ
الدكتور دويدار والعلافه النظر اليهم
بتؤرخ وبتسجل
ان لما جاء عمرو بن العاص لمصر ولا غيرها
من الاقاليم اقر النظام اللي موجود ما
عملش فيه حاجه اذا كان مثلا حد بيشرب خمره
فمنعها اوكي ماشي اذا كانت مثلا اذا كان
اذا كان الشكل اللباس او اقامه المساجد
والصلوات اوكي الجمع الجزيه من غير
المسلمين او الزكاه دي تغييرات موجوده بس
مش تغييرات عميقه مش مش بتعمل تغيير عميق
في شكل السياسه الخارجيه والسياسه
الداخليه وهذا ما اقصده اذا كان ما قلته
ليس كافين يبقى استاذنك اطرحه مره تانيه
وهنعمل الحلقه اللي انا ماجلها من يجي
ثلاث اربع سنين والسبب انه دائما في احداث
اللي هي ماذا لو حكم الاسلاميون انا اسف
ولم تفعل فعلا لان بلاء السودان بلاقي
سوريا بلاقي كذا
فاتمنى تكون الاجابات القصيره وبالمناسبه
مش لازم اكون صح يعني انا اكيد مش لازم
اكون صح ما انا عارف يعني يعني اقصد اقول
رايي انا ممكن اصلا اغيره بس انا ما توافر
اليه وما توافر لكثير من اصدقائي واساتذتي
اللي بنتكلم حتى في غرف مغلقه بدون لائقه
جندات ولا بتاع ولا عنده هذا ما اعلمه
يعني قعدنا انا عاوز اقول لكم على حاجه
ولا بلاش لانه يعني مش خلاص يعني انا اجبت
لانه
اصله لو اتكلمنا يعني يعني احنا عندنا
تجارب يعني انت عندك نظام الاسلامي يعني
مثلا نظر له حسن الترابي وطبقوا البشير
لسنوات طويله ايه هو اللي اضافه يعني ايه
هي الحاجه اللي ميزته عن غيره وخلت انه
كذا عندك طالبان عندها تجربه ليست قصيره
وطبعا ارجوكم ما تكونش الاجابه انهم لم
يعطوا فرصه لان الجميع يحاربهم الجميع
بيحارب الجميع مين اللي ادى فرصه للصين ان
هي تعمل نظامها مين اللي ادى فرصه
للاتحاد السوفيتي مين اللي اد فرصه
لاي دوله كل دوله بتحاول انها تحقق رؤيه
بتعارض مع الدول الاوبل للدا فرصه لايران
مين اللي فرصه لدول الخليج كل دوله بتحارب
من مصادر خطيره وخارجيه خارجيه خطيره ولكن
اذا كان النموذج قابل للتطبيق بيحقق
نجاحها
استاذ سيد لماذا لا تفتح حساب تويتر
تنرنا بتعليقاتك وارائك ابو حنين
كان في بعض الاصدقاء طرحوها بس انا مش
عارف ما بعرفش استخدمه انا عارف ان انا
هكتب تعليقات 140 كلمه ولا 200 كلمه بس
انا عاده مش نشط قوي في ان انا بقول راس
صغيره انا عاده بشتغل على قضيه باخد عليها
اسبوع عشره ايام اكتر اقل وبعبر عنها في
وقت كتير فمش حس ان نموذج التويتر كما
افهمه ممكن يبقى مناسب ليا
اذا كنت انت في تصور تاني ممكن تقول لي
انا بكل سرور استفيد من رايك وممكن تكتبوا
لي هنا او تكتبه لي حتى في رساله على
فيسبوك
اسعد بيك وشكرا جزيلا لمقترحك
[موسيقى]
يعني الحاجات دي كتير
ايه يمنع الحكومه المصريه اجابنا الامارات
ستعلن اعجبنا او يعني قرانا هل تراجع
التضخم معناه تقليل سعر المنتجات او تراجع
زياده سعر المنتجات ولو تراجع زياده سعر
المنتجات وهذا يعني لا يمكن للمنجد ان
تتخفض اسعار الا ان التضخم يكون انا فهمت
سؤالك احمد بيقول بيسال عن معنى التضخم
يعني التضخم يا اخونا العزيز اعتبر ان
الاسعار زي ما كانوا بيشرحوا لنا يعني انه
الاسعار زي سياره
بتسير على الطريق في طريق مفتوح هي بتسير
في كل الاحوال العربيه مش متوقفه
التضخم معناها معدل سرعه السير مش توقف
السير الاسعار كده كده بترتفع
السلعه اللي انت بتشتريها النهارده بميه
اذا كانت تضخم بعشره السنه الجايه هتبقى ب
110 اذا كانت تضخم ب 110 هتزيد عشره في
الميه وهكذا على الميه وعشره
ابتدت تضخم يتراجع بدل الزياده مكانه مثلا
بمعدل مستمره عشره في الميه بقت 5%
التراجع الخمسه في الميه ده من زياده في
الاسعار مش انخفاض الاسعار يعني مش هترجع
تبقى اصل السلعه كان ب 100 هيبقى ب90 ولكن
السلعه كانت ب 100 ونفترض نفترض ان التضخم
10% يبقى السلعه دي هتشتريها السنه الجايه
ب 110 طيب اذا حصل تراجع في التضخم بقت
التضخم بقت خمسه بدل ما هو عشره معناها ان
متوسط الزياده في العام المقبل لن يكون
10% زائد الميه وعشره ولكن هيكون
يعني يعني معدل الزياده سوف يتراجع امتى
يحصل انخفاض للاسعار لما يحصل بقى انكماش
ان السلعه اللي كانت ب 110 او 115 بسبب
التضخم لا رجعت تاني ل 100 ثم بقت 99 ثم
98 وده يبقى شيء سيء بالمناسبه لان ده
يبقى انكماش عكس التضخم ده يبقى عنده
مشاكل تانيه خالص انما مشاكل تانيه خالص
لان المنتج هيبتدي يلاقي مشاكل في التكلفه
والمستهلك هيتوقع ان السرعه اللي ب 100
بكره هتبقى بتسعه وتسعين
الركود البضائع تتكدس المصانع تخرج بره
الخدمه يبقى في مشاكل في الجهاز المصرفي
انما
ان الحاجه تبقى 100 السنه الجايه تبقى ب
102 103 104 في الدوله المتقدمه في الدول
الناشئه ممكن 105 106 107 معقول اكتر من
كده تبقى فيها مشاكل
هل مصلحه السعوديه في انفصال اليمن سؤال
صعب جدا جدا جدا وعاوز فيه دبيت اخذ ورد
لا استطيع ان السؤال مطروح من سنين على كل
الاحوال يعني
انما اقدر اقول لك ان ممكن تكون في مصلحه
مثلا لدوله الامارات لانه مصالحها متحققه
تقريبا في الجنوب والسواحل ممكن يكون لدي
مصلحه هل ده مصلحه للسعوديه
اشك يعني
التضخم اجرنا مساله التضخم
نتمنى حلقه عن الاقتصاد السوري لان بعض
السوريين يعتقدون اقتصاد سوريا كبير جدا
اكبر من السعوديه والامارات في النفط
والغاز والزراعه لا اعلم هذا هي اكبر ناتج
محل اجمالي لسوريا كان في 2010 كان رقم مش
قليل كان حوالي 250 260 مليار دولار
بالنسبه لبلد عدد سكانها حوالي 20 مليون
اذا كان الرقم دقيق عندي في اول 2010
وارجو ان تصححوني يعني كان جيد
لما يكون سوريا ما عندهاش الثروات اللي
عند يعني البترول والغاز اللي عندي طبعا
دول الخليج لكن هي بلد كان عندهم مقومات
اخرى كانت يمكن ان تسمح له بانه يكون
[موسيقى]
لكن عموما حاضر ان شاء الله
سوريا برضه فيها صعوبه انت عندك بلد انهار
وتحطمت معظم مدنه
وفي حاجه اهم من المدن ان كثير من الكوادر
دي خرج بره سوريا
عودتهم صعبه يعني ظروف صعبه فانت اللي
تقدر تتكلم عليه هو الامل فيه ان الحياه
تدور اتمنى تكون عمليه التطبيع الاخيره
ديت وبدء المفرد تكون امل ان الحياه تبتدي
ترجع مش ازدهار بقى ولكن الحياه تبقى
مقبوله في سوريا يعني
ما رايك باقتصاد السعوديه بالفتره الاخيره
اقتصادها هو شوف يعني ما في شك انه
ما يتوفر لنا من معلومات وانا ما عنديش
يعني الواضح ان في طفره الطفره دي بتقول
ايه ان الامور اللي كانت مش محل اهتمام
[موسيقى]
يعني في تغير كبير
التغير ده بمعايير الاقتصاد ومعايير
السياسه اذا استمر على هذا الشكل مع
الامكانات الاقتصاديه الكبيره اللي عندهم
يقول والله في امر يستحق التوقف
[موسيقى]
ويستحق المشاهده
باعجاب اذا اكتملت التجربه على هذا النحو
لانه برضو هيبقى عنده مطالبات اخرى على
المدى البعيد هيبقى فين اقتصادي لازم
يتبعه انفتاح سياسي ودي قصه مش عاجله لكن
هتكون مطروحه يعني
هل رد المقاومه الفلسطينيه ممكن يخلي
اسرائيل توقف ضرباتها لغزه ولو بشكل مؤقت
ما هي اصل استاذ اسلام السيكل المعروفه
طبعا ما فيش وجه للمقارنه ولا كذا
وان طبعا تكون يعني
بيستخدموا وسيله ردع بس بشكل غير متكافئ
اسرائيل مش عاوزه تعكر حركه النقل في
مطرها مش عاوزه بيت يتهدم مش عاوزه واحد
يقتل لكن هي علشان تمنع ده بتقوم بعمليه
قصف عنيف جدا تقتل في مقابله مئات وتهدم
احياء بالكامل فالاثنين بيقولوا ان بعد
فتره اسرائيل مش هتقدر يعني تدمر كل غزه
وكل بعد فتره بتتوقف وكمان
المقاومه بتجهد وعاده دول بتدخل الوساطه
اهمها مصر بس بتكون يعني التكلفه عنيفه
جدا على الفلسطينيين خصوصا بانه
انه
يعني البيئه الحاضنه لهم من الدول العربيه
تراجعت كثيرا يعني
ايه يمنع اسلام اجابنا
انت يا حسني انا وصلتني رساله الامارات
ستعلن انفصال جنوب اليمن وفقا لحسني بيقول
كده هذا توقعك او معلومتك خلاص انا فهمتها
خلاص شكرا جزيلا اخونا العزيز التراجع
التضخم معناه تقليل سعر المنتجات وتراجع
زياده سعر المنتجات
الانفصال يمن يتعارض مع اجنده السعوديه
هي عمليه اسلوب
هيبقى فيه ما هو اصله القصه برضو ايه
تتدرس من نواع كتيره هو يتوقف على شكل
اليمن
يعني في النهايه مثلا
احنا قدام متغيرات اهم متغير بالنسبه
لمساله الشمال انه اللي انا شايفه في
الفتره
القادمه انه السعوديه عاوز تخرج من اليمن
وتوقف عشان تخرج من حرب اليمن وتوقف
الخسائر اللي عندها لازم تتفاوض مع مين
هتتفاوض مع الحوثيين لان هي بتقر ان
الحوثيين هم القوه اللي موجوده واصبحنا
امام دوله موجوده في شمال
في شمال اليمن
والسعوديين بيعددوا شرحتهم بالتفاوض معاهم
هي وغيرهم اذا اصبحنا امام وضع جديد لا
يمكن دول الجنوبها تقبل
بالحوثيين دوله موحده لهم وهم ما عندهمش
مشكله وان يفقدوا الشمال فهنبقى فكره اذا
اقروا بوجود الحوثيين في الشمال يبقى
بيقروا بان فيه دوله في الجنوب
قد يكون ده امر واقع زي ما في امر واقع في
دول اخرى كثيره لكن المشكله في الجنوب عن
اي جنوب البائع يتحدث عن جنوب واحد متماسك
ولا عده دويلات في الجنوب في القصه تتوقف
على الشكل النهائي
وممكن تحدث المعجزه ودول اخرى تقنع كل
الدول كل الاطراف اللي موجوده في اليمن
ولو ان دي مهمه صعبه جدا جدا جدا جدا وما
حدش عنده استعداد للاستثمار فيها انه يعني
يتفق على حكومه واحده بس ده
سيناريو صعب يعني انا استاذنكم خمس دقايق
كمان ونتوقف
اسئله كتير
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد لماذا المغرب ودول
اخرى تعرض التطبيع كل دوله يا اخونا لها
سبب المغرب قالت بشار الاسد متحالف مع
ايران وهما يدعمان اجابه البوليساريو ودي
خط احمر بالنسبه للمغرب
الحكومه اليمنيه قالت ان هو بيدعم
الحوثيين
والصوت الممثل في المحافل الدوليه هي ما
يسمى بحكومه الشرعيه
القطر اسهمنا في الكلام عنها هي ترى انه
والله انا لن اسير مع القطيع وخلاص هم
قالوا لي طبع طبع انا شايفه انه هي عاوزه
بتقول انا سياسه الخارجيه بتقوم على
احترام حقوق الانسان وكذا وبالتالي لن
اسلم بالامر الواقع بالاضافه ان لها مصالح
اخرى تتمنى ان هي تتم بعيدا عن الاسد
استاذنك ارجع للحلقه الاخيره انا
افهم الاحداث في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ضمن
التغيرات العالميه الصين وروسيا
تحاول بناء حلفاء اقوياء في مواجهه الجي 7
لذلك يسعى
الجميع الى الحلول في المنطقه خصوصا تركيا
مصر ايران السعوديه اذا كنت انا فهمت فهمك
فهو انا هذا اتفق معك في نظام جديد في
تحالفات جديده
فطبعا
ايوه يعني كما افهم كلامك اتفق معك ايه
يمنع اجابنا
اطلب حلقه عن اطلب حقا عن التحركات
الاقتصاديه السعوديه في قناه نعرف اقتصاد
رجاء ان شاء الله حاضر عوض عبد الجوادي ان
شاء الله لماذا العرب يكرهون ايران اجابنا
انا افهم اجابنا هل الحكام العرب جواسيس
حلفهم الحظ اكثر من
هو علي رضا اكبري وسعاد الخولي واليك وهين
انا اعتقد انه السؤال تتكرر بس
لا اتفق مع الطرح من اساسه يعني كلام لا
يبدو منطقيا يعني لكن لا علم لي على الاقل
يعني
عجبنا يمنع عجبنا عجبنا
سيد جبيل عايز افهم ما هي هويه الدوله
يعني انت هويه الدوله انت بتيجي تقول مثلا
كان في تعبير يقولوا عليه في العلوم
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
يعني سبب الوجود يعني الاهداف الرئيسيه
لدوله يعني لما تيجي دوله زي ايران تقول
والله انا دوله اسلاميه اقوم على انه
الاسلام هو الحل ونصره المستضعفين وانه لا
شرقيه ولا غربيه ولازم اعتمد على ذاتي فده
بيحدد سياساتها الخارجيه لما تيجي دوله
تقول والله مثلا زي قطر تقول انا سياستي
الخارجيه هتعتمد على ان اكون
داعمه لكل الراغبين في التحرر من الانظمه
الشموليه
وكذا وان انا بسعى في المستقبل الملكيه
دستوريه معناها ان هي لن تكون متماهيه مع
سياسه الامارات والسعوديه لن تكون داعمه
لاي نظم عسكريه او ملكيه رغمانيه طب ملكي
بس بيقول انا عاوز ابقى نظام دستوري لما
تكون دوله وهكذا يعني ايه هويه الدوله
يعني الهدف الاساسي الاول اللي بتحكمها
اذا كانت سياسيه او اقتصاديه بتخليها تاخد
خطوات تصيغ هذه الاولات في شكل سياسه
علي محمد انت مصر على نفس السؤال يا محمد
ما يضمن لنا ان حكامنا ليس ادوات بيد موسى
انا اجبت سؤالك يا استاذ علي مش عارف يعني
لا شيء يضمن غير المنطق يعني لكن
بخصوص امتحان السلك الدبلوماسي ما هي
المحاور التي يجب ذكرها في اي مقال سياسي
يا ساره انا عارف ان في كثير من الراغبين
في
الانضمام للسلك الدبلوماسي بيتابعوا
القناه باعتبار ان هي بتطرح موضوعات بتبقى
يعني بتساعدهم في تجاوز وكتير قالوا لي
الكلام ده سواء من الخارجيه او من الطلبه
سواء في مصر او غيرها يعني لكن انا لا
اعلم الشروط
[موسيقى]
سامحيني لما تيجي فرصه ويكون عندنا ضيف
هنا دبلوماسي نبقى نساله
سامحيني يا ساره معلش والله انا حابب بس
انا فعلا ما اعرفش يعني
يمكن اقدر اساعدك تاني لانه ما هي المحاور
التي ذكرها في اي مقال سياسي او سؤال
سياسه دوليه لي يغطي المشهد ككل وشكرا
لحضرتك لا سامحيني مش قادره افهم السؤال
معلش اكتفي افضل ان انا اقول ما اعرفش
يعني
الان السؤالين الاول برايك لماذا استمر
الانهيار الاقتصادي وبوتيره اقوى من بعد
بعد مصلحه الثاني بعد مش عارف برايك ان
بدا اعاده الاعمار على سوريا بعدها
الاعمار ما مع مساعدتهم كبيره كم سنه
تحتاج سوري لتعود الاقتصاد جيد شوف انا مش
فاهم السؤال الاول تقريبا بتقول لماذا
استمر الانهيار الاقتصادي
يعني اذا كنت فهمت السؤال لان في الكلام
داخل في بعضه احمد
المتاعب الاقتصاديه في سوريا اللي انت
بتشير اليها نتيجه منطقيه لدوله تم
تحطيمها يعني تقريبا فطبيعي انا عارف ان
في ناس وليه اصدقاء سافر ودمشقي حتى كان
بعضهم يعني جاي من مدن اوروبيه وبيقتل
اجازاته انه الحياه مش زي ما الناس ولكن
الحياه صعبه جدا على السوريين اللي
موجودين صعبه ده تفسيره منطقي خالص يعني
فاعتقد ان ده واضح اذا كنت فهمت سؤالك لكن
السؤال التاني كم سنه تحتاج ده هيتوقف على
سرعه اندماج سوريا في محيطها وبالتالي
قدره الدول العربيه من الحصول على اهدافها
وبالتالي بث مساعدات لسوريا
واقناع الغربي برفع العقوبات دي تبقى
عوامل هتحتاج على حسب المفاوضات اذا
اتفقوا على ده ودي حاجه صعبه جدا يمكن
المساله ان هي خلال فتره قليله جدا لانه
معنى كده ان خلال سنه سنتين تبدا الجرافات
والادوات ويبداوا في عمليه البنوي ووظفوا
سوريين
وسنتين تلاته
فاضل اربع دقائق واستاذنهم نكتفي مستقبل
الوضع على الارض
مستقبل الوضع على الارض للسوريه بوجود
الاسد كامر واقع اليد على الارض تحت حكم
الاكراد والاتراك
ولا ولو لا يبقى ايه مستقبل
الاراضي برضو محمد ماهر محمد ماهر نشط جدا
ما شاء الله ما هو المساله هتختلف زي ما
بقول لحضرتك على انه حجم وهو اوريدي
بيسيطر على معظم الاراضي السوريه فاضل بقى
فكره حل قضيتهم مع الاكراد حل قضيته مع
العشره في الميه اللي بتحتل لها تركيا او
الجامعات المؤيده لها الخلافات في دول في
المناطق الجنوبيه كلها قابله
لمسار المفاوضات مع الاطراف المختلفه فلسه
الكلام ده مطروح لسه مش مهتمه بالجنوب
والجنوب على نفسه واهم من الانقسام اليمني
مصالح الدول الخارجيه الدول الخارجيه لها
وكلاء وليها حلفاء ودول مصالحهم كل واحد
له مصلحه خارجيه لها وكلاء وليها حلفاء
ودول مصالحهم كل واحد لهم مصلحه ولما دوله
بينفرد عقدها احيانا يعني جمع مره اخرى
صعب لان مفيش دوله مركزيه زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم في اول الحلقه والاطراف الخارجيه
كل دوله بتخدم مصالحها بس ومصالح الدول
الخارجيه مش بالضروره يتفق مع مصالح
العامه لكن حتى لو وصلنا للسناريو لناس
كثيره ما كانتش تتمناه ويبقى في جنوب بس
وشمال بس
نتمنى يعني انه ده يكون احسن من الوضع
اللي هم يكونوا موجودين وفي حاله انقسام
جنوب على جنوب وجنوب كله ضد الشمال
سيد جبيل عازب افهم اجابناه ما هو مصير
لبنان من هذا الصرع الاقليمي وبالاخص بعد
عوده سوريا الى طاوله القمه العربيه يفترض
انه يكون وضعه احسن لان الخلافات
الايرانيه السعوديه كانت اكثر ما يعرق
للاتفاق اللبناني نتمنى دلوقتي انه يكون
دي فرصه لعمليه
ذوبان للخلافات الخارجيه على الاراضي
اللبنانيه ويا سلام لو رفعوا العقوبات بقى
عن سوريا يبقى حاجه عظيمه جدا
هل فعلا من الممكن
ان تقوم الحكومه تركيا الجديده المعارضه
اذا وصلت للسلطه ان تقوم بطرد اللاجئين
اعلنت هي اله انه اذا جئت الى السلطه فانا
عندي تصور التصور الوحيد اللي عندي انه
الشركات التركيه تقوم ببناء اماكن
للاجئين باموال اوروبيه ويعود هؤلاء
اللاجئين في اسرع وقت ممكن واذا لم
يساعدني الاتحاد الاوروبي اسف سوف افتح
ابوابي يعني اللاجئين يروحوا في اي حته
وطبعا هم مش هيروحوا سوريا هيروحوا اوروبا
انا اسف ان انا عارف ان في اسئله كثيره
بسم الله ما شاء الله احنا لسه عندنا عدد
كبير بس سامحوني لانه انا قتلت كثيرا على
الناس مش كده برضو يا ماندو
بعتذر عن حاجتين الحاجه الاولانيه انه لم
اتمكن من اجابه كل الاسئله ان شاء الله
نطرحها في الحلقه المقبله وبمناسبه الحلقه
المقبله انا هعمل استفتاء بكره هقول لكم
اذا اردتم ان يكون هذا اللقاء بدل ما هو
نصف شهر اسبوعي يكون عندنا فرصه اكبر
وبعتذر مره تانيه عن انقطاع الارسال اكثر
من مره قبل ان يعني
ننجح يبدو ان في مشكله في فكره البث من
خلال كاميرا عاديه هنشوف القصه دي مره
تانيه وكان الاعتذاري واشكركم واراكم على
خير الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله